Thank you.
All right, Melissa.
I'm just going to hang out for about 10 minutes and see.
I mean, obviously you showed up, so we have someone.
But before I start rambling on, I figured I'll wait to see.
I'm in New England, and so it's right in the middle of the blizzard right now.
I guess it's right at the beginning of the blizzard, although we've gotten quite a bit of snow, so...
It was this trend for a while, and I don't know if it was intentional or what, it doesn't seem to still be the case with the UFOX spaces.
And I only wound up, like, I know I always say this, but I only wound up sort of in the UFOX orbit by mistake.
I'm not really a fan or I'm not really a fan of the UFOX content creators, and just because I saw the Doom Room and Morgan and Dan needed to get some information out, and the Doom Room seemed like a good opportunity because it seemed as if the people who attended the Doom Room were sort of like kind of horror consumers almost, right?
Like, they're into conspiracy consumers, conspiratainment, and horror consumers, and so the core intuitive underground material, obsession material, what Morgan refers to as the canon material, you know, it's kind of, it's very dark.
So, it occurred to me, like, when I found this random online space, I said, this is the perfect opportunity to get some practice in with an audience who's not going to be disturbed, right?
Or not that disturbed, or if they are disturbed, it's not going to be because of what we say.
So, and then, next thing you know, I, you know, Morgan said, hey, why don't we do some spaces?
And I said, yeah, okay, that's great.
And we just kind of got lumped into UFOX, and I'm not a, I mean, I, I spent a couple years attending, hey, Sally, hey, Sadie, you know, I spent a couple years attending, like, a couple of MUFON things, and, you know, talking to some MUFON people back in the 90s, and, you know, following, that was a different, it was a different scene back then, like, completely different scene than what, whatever's going on in UFOX.
Like, like, the presuppositions were different, like, everyone was actually interested in aliens, as opposed to, like, everyone being interested in finding something to explain the subject that isn't involved in aliens, and it wasn't, it was a, a social gathering, but it wasn't entertainment.
And, you know, I think it's a big difference between when you, which is sort of unusual today, it's like, to, to go in, and meet a bunch of strangers and have a, like, in real life, social interaction is very rare nowadays.
It was not at that time in the 90s, although probably getting rarer.
And, and so, like, just a big difference between the, the social underpinnings of ufology at the time and the entertainment underpinnings of ufology today.
Just completely different presuppositions.
And, I don't know, they, they, UFOX claims to be ufology, but they don't, the, the content creators don't believe in aliens.
So, it's just like a, it's a semantic thing, where they say, well, we think there's something, but, you know, we think it's genies, or, or, you know, ancient Atlanteans, or, you know, something like that.
We don't believe in aliens.
They don't lead with that, right?
Like, it's not, like, when you go to the UFOX website, or the, not, sorry, the, the group site on X, UFOX, it doesn't say, we don't believe in aliens.
So, it's kind of, like, to draw people in, who probably do believe in aliens, and then the content creators spend a lot of time, kind of, subtly trying to disincentivize people to believe in aliens.
So, that, that, that's a very real thing.
Like, Tupacabra and Logan, they don't believe in aliens.
And, uh, Red, they don't believe in aliens.
Like, they, it comes out in discussions they have every once in a while.
It's not something they talk about, like, they don't, like, you know, put it out on the table, like I said, because they, they want the, the audience.
But they all believe that whatever it is, it's something else, whether it's the government or whatnot.
And, uh, so I would never naturally get drawn to UFOX because, um, you know, when I was younger and sort of, you know, had some casual interactions with ufology, like, it definitely wasn't a thing where we were trying to find out, like, the secret weapon systems the government has, you know?
Like, that was, that's kind of crazy.
And, um, it's, it's like, to have that, like, as a form of entertainment is kind of, like, um, disassociated, you know?
Because if you actually got information, like, if you got close to what, you know, information on the secret weapon systems the government has, like, you're, you're in big trouble.
That's, that's no joke.
Um, and to have people get together and think it's a joke, that's kind of bizarre.
So I never would have gotten involved with that if it hadn't been for the Doom Room and getting Morgan's information out.
And, uh, anyhow, there was this thing where they would all, I don't know, you guys have all been there, I'm sure, right?
They would all, um, they would want to start with, like, 100 people or 50 people or something.
And so they would start their space 20 minutes early, and then everyone would sit there in silence.
So I go to these spaces, and I was like, what the fuck is going on?
No, sorry for my language.
Um, so, you know, what is going on here?
There's, like, 40 people.
Is it, like, um, a wake or something?
Is it, like, some sort of weird digital online wake where everyone's just, like, having a moment of silence?
And still no one ever explained it to me, but I just assumed it was so that they could get their numbers up before they started the space for some sort of, like, cloud or rep or something.
Um, that's just my assumption.
I don't know.
That's what makes sense to me.
Uh, based on my knowledge now, I've had some interactions with some of the key players, and that's, you know, it doesn't matter.
No matter what an influencer talks about, they're all interested in being influencers, not interested in the subject they're talking about.
And that's just, that's universal.
Um, in my experience.
Okay, so, uh, last week, or the week before, uh, we had a space, and I was talking about, um, what's going on with the long-term astrological cycles and how it explains what's happening in, you know, in the world right now.
Like, these, if, I think, remote viewers, like, very accomplished remote viewers or experienced remote viewers who do a lot of session work are not,
super surprised at a lot of the events, but I think they're still surprised by some of them.
But a competent astrologer should not be surprised at anything that's happening in the world right now, or has happened, because it's, it's very clearly spelled out in the astrology.
Um, and we've had discussions going on for quite some time.
As a matter of fact, the reason I originally, so I originally, um, got back in X after years of not, you know, using Twitter.
Um, because, um, I was deeply concerned about the fact that astrologers were not being honest with people.
That, you know, they were all, because everyone views now alternative thinking as a form of entertainment, uh, they felt, um, entitled to, um, not tell people about how serious the global situation was.
And the global situation was serious in 2022, 2023, right?
So it's since, it's been since COVID, right?
Um, and like, we've never had, um, we, so there were some nuclear weapons were used, but we've never had like a, a full scale nuclear war.
We don't know what that looks like from an astrological perspective, right?
So if someone says to me, well, I want you to predict when and if nuclear war is going to happen.
Like, I can't do that, honestly, because the, the chart of the nuclear age is only, I don't know, was it 1941, 1943?
I think it's 43, but it could be 41.
I don't know.
I have the date.
I've used the chart for a long time, but things kind of fuzzy in my mind, right?
So, um, yeah, so we don't know.
Now there was a very serious astrological, um, transit to the natal chart of the nuclear age.
Uh, Uranus, um, opposite the natal Mars.
And that's very explosive.
That's what UFO X is going through right now.
They're going through a Uranus conjunction to natal Mars.
So all the, like, the craziness and those crazy threats and, uh, like the, the Charlie Kirk thing.
And when the people freaked out and like divided into two camps or whatever, that's because Uranus was conjunct, um, ufology's natal Mars, the Roswell chart, the natal Mars for the Roswell chart, um, in Gemini.
Um, so it's an explosive crisis that creates division, um, as in the third house.
So it's communication and short distance travel.
Um, so anyways, we were going through something similar with the, uh, chart of the nuclear age.
And the reason I reactivated my account, um, wasn't to troll anyone, but it was to bottom line a few people, uh, who are very active in the astrology community who were not being honest about what was going on.
Like I wanted to approach them and say, look, uh, in social media, in a public forum, because I had had some correspondence with them behind the scenes and people were like, straight up, like, I'm not talking about this.
Right.
And so you could talk to them publicly about it and at least get them on the record.
But prior to that, like, I would, I would have correspondence with people and they're like, wait, I am not talking about nuclear weapons, uh, on my astrology channel, uh, in my astrology books at all, ever anything.
And from my perspective, if you have an idea, if you, if you have a, a strong clue that something's going to happen, like, you know, it's, it's an imperfect science.
So we're not going to know a hundred percent, but if you have a, a strong idea, like this is a time when there could be a problem.
You have an obligation to tell people like it could, yeah, it could affect your influence.
Maybe people don't take you as seriously because thank God it didn't happen.
Right.
You're like, okay, uh, April, uh, 2024 rolls around and, uh, we do not have a nuclear exchange.
All right.
So now the people talking about it, maybe they've lost 10% of their credibility and they shouldn't have, because they should have right couched it the correct way.
So that people knew they were saying, well, this is a chance, but we're not saying it's going to happen.
But, you know, in order to avoid that, like losing face, a little bit of losing face or a little bit of losing credibility or a little bit of income, my people would just not say, like, Hey, this is a real possibility.
And so had it happened or, or when it happens, right.
If it does, um, the people who didn't warn other people, like they're, they have those lives on their hands.
So it's, it's very important to talk about the, um, you know, strong negative, um, indications in astrology and remote viewing, any predictive science like this, that's what we're here for.
Okay.
So I know that like people get involved in like cults and people make doomsday predictions and I get that whole thing.
And yeah, you know, it, it leads to, it's why you should never say, look, it's going to happen on this day.
Right.
Because it does lead to people not taking, um, future disasters seriously.
So that's important.
But you also have to let people know, like, look, there are windows of opportunity.
This is what we're talking about, windows of opportunity and where things can happen.
And, you know, instead of windows of opportunity for bad things to happen, we should have windows of preparedness.
Right.
So anyways.
Uh, so yeah, I mean, I, I kind of got involved.
To, um, to keep track of the people who weren't talking about what they should be talking about.
And it's kind of interesting.
Cause then when I got into, um, you know, it's accidentally wandered into UFO X, I found a bunch of other people doing the exact same thing.
Right.
And then, uh, I started doing, I started doing spaces with Morgan and damned if they weren't doing the exact same thing.
Like pretty much everyone is, you know, involved in, you know, trying to make money and not telling people the negative.
Things that they know, right.
Like remote viewers have, oh my God.
Every remote viewer has, um, a, a pile of back section, session work that they never going to release.
They have files of sessions.
They have, they have targets.
They don't want to release it.
Some of it's personal.
Some of it's like, um, NDA, but a lot of it is just, they don't want to release the information.
They have, uh, the perceptions they have, because they don't want it to affect their public reputation.
Um, depending on how people will respond to that information.
Right.
So like they, they've got all kinds of stuff about, I don't know, tidal waves and solar flares and right.
You know, uh, geopolitical stuff.
Um, and I knew that this was going on.
So I said, look, let's, we got to release this information that you have.
We got to get it out to people.
It's a moral obligation.
And I was, I'm not talking any shit.
I'm just, right.
Perceptions can vary.
So this is my perception of the situation, but I'm not trying to mischaracterize anyone's
behavior.
Okay.
Or decisions or anything.
So, um, you know, I said, uh, we're going to get this information out.
And I, I fall into this trap of like, not overestimating people.
Like I, I, I believe in people sometimes that they're going to see the light or they're going
to understand the situation.
And so I really, I really got the idea that if we, if we started to bring out some of this
information, then we would release all of the information and this perhaps would make
it more comfortable for other remote viewers to release their information.
Right.
Cause they have it.
And, um, they have a lot of it on the simulation.
They have a lot of it on extraterrestrials and they have a lot of it on, on future events,
um, concerning, uh, future, potential future crises.
And, uh, this is not what happened.
This is not what happened.
As a matter of fact, uh, I think in my opinion, I feel that the remote viewers I was working with
felt exposed.
I believe they had pressure exerted on them, um, by other remote viewers.
And I believe that, uh, as the result of that, they, they stopped releasing any information
as opposed to releasing more information.
Um, and I don't think that I had anything to do with like all the remote viewers.
Um, but maybe my associates did, um, or maybe it's just like the, the zeitgeist because everyone
sort of started to scale back the amount of information they released, um, as opposed to releasing more
of it.
Um, so, um, for instance, I can give you one example.
Like there's intuitive underground session work on the China U S crisis.
And if you understand the crisis with the U S and China, like right now, that's happening
right now, like everything that's happening in the world makes more sense.
Like Venezuela makes more sense.
Right.
Um, uh, Iran makes more sense.
Uh, Greenland makes more sense.
Right.
And if you had this, this session information, like people who, uh,
who believed it or were willing to entertain it, like could have a better understanding of
why.
Right.
So like what in my, to my recollection, what the, the basic gist of the session information
was, was that following the revelation that China had achieved technological parity with
the U S in some areas, there would be this geopolitical crisis.
And, you know, uh, about a month or two before all this stuff with Greenland and began trying
to kind of started releasing, I mean, every day there was a new news headline from China
about some sort of new technology, cold fusion, um, computer chips, uh, medical related.
And as soon as this started to happen, I said, okay, this we're going to, we're headed for
the geopolitical crisis.
Now the war is going to escalate.
And the next step that the U S is going to make is, um, hold on.
I have to turn the mic off for one second.
Uh, I had to become a cat's dormant again.
And so I had to let the cat out cause he was starting to scold me.
Okay.
So yeah, as soon as this started to happen, I said, look, um, you know, we're going to start
to consolidate power in this hemisphere.
And we have to write, um, the same with, regardless of what you, an individual's personal feelings
are, um, about the political situation.
And I'm not, I'm not political and it's, it's tough even as a non-political person to
see what's happening.
Um, there are foreign interests involved in U S politics.
And as we get closer to, uh, if we, I mean, you know, hope, I hope to God that a miracle
happens and we don't have a confrontation, but as we get closer to an open confrontation,
right, that's going to affect U S politics.
It's going to affect politics in Western countries.
It's going to affect NATO.
It's going to affect all of that because some of these individuals are influenced by the countries
we're going to be, um, we might have a confrontation with, right?
So it, it comes down to like in the past, you had a couple of, at least in this country,
you had a couple of different cultures sort of feuding with each other off and on.
And then, you know, foreign political, um, propagandists get involved and they use the internet
and social media sort of ratchet up that tension.
But then once we're at that point where it's like, okay, we're, we're likely going to fight
a war, um, then, you know, one or more political side, they've been accepting money and, and
taking help from these other nations.
Right.
And so regardless of, at that point, regardless of what you think is correct, personally, ethically
and morally, it's not going to stop.
What's going to happen because, you know, once we're going to get in a conflict, right.
They're going to, things are going to happen domestically as well.
So, and that's in the astrology.
Um, so Lou was here.
Lou actually is the one who inspired this, um, this space.
So, uh, we were talking about, uh, these astrological cycles and what was, was likely to occur.
Um, and at the very end, when I had to go, Lou was like, well, what, how does this affect,
um, the archons and escaping from the archons?
And I said, well, that's a great topic.
Uh, but I can't talk about it today.
So we'll talk about it again soon.
That's what we're here to do today.
However, I, I do have to interject and say, like for people listening, both all of you guys,
and thank you, you're all my, you're always here for the spaces, Sadie and Sal and Lou
and Melissa and Sin and Sally.
It's great to see you've been here for some spaces.
Sally's a great astrologer.
Um, so what's going on?
Like, I just got to cover this quickly.
So the reason that things are, are suddenly, um, sort of the crisis that these crises that
have been there suddenly seem to be flaring up, um, is when you have these, uh, outer planet,
um, cyanotic cycles, or like, even if you're talking about a personal natal chart, if you
have, um, certain natal transit, transit to your natal chart, uh, sometimes, um, if you
want to time the exact events, uh, the best tool to do that is either with, uh, an eclipse
or with, uh, transits of, of Mars.
Mars is an initiator.
Um, and it's sort of part of Mars's, um, right.
It's sort of, it's sort of part of, um, Mars's astrological impact.
And it's, it's sort of, um, yeah, anyways, Mars is an initiator.
And so when, when Mars will cross over, uh, a long-term conjunction.
So if you have, um, we'll give you an example, uh, 2024 Pluto entered Aquarius and right around
that time, a little bit before its final entry into Aquarius, uh, October 7th happened.
And so whenever, um, whenever, uh, an outer planet moves into a new sign, but particularly
with Pluto, whenever Pluto moves into a new sign, there is an event.
Um, and that event is like, um, the outbreak of AIDS or, um, the Oklahoma city bombing or the,
um, the financial crisis of, uh, two on 2009, right.
There was an event that immediately keys you into what the big, um, the folk, what the focus
is, what the big events are going to be, uh, during the, the next period.
Now, Pluto transits vary, uh, the time that they're in, the time it's in certain signs can
go anywhere from 12 years to more than 20 years.
Right.
I think almost 30 years.
Um, and I should know this all, but I phase out on things.
So I do know it, but I get spacing.
Um, however, Mars just, um, Mars just entered, uh, Aquarius and in doing so it activated, uh,
Pluto's Ingress into Aquarius.
And this would happen in a natal chart as well.
So like, for instance, um, my, my ascendant is at 215, um, Aquarius.
So actually right now, um, tonight, and I'm, I'm not an important person.
If I was like a world leader or something, you see a big event.
Um, but right now, uh, Mars is crossing over my first house and it's activating the long-term,
um, transit of Pluto to my ascendant.
Okay.
And it's probably why we're, I'm having this conversation.
Like if I was a famous person, it would be something, you know, remarkable.
I'm not a famous person.
So it's something small.
I mean, this is a very important conversation.
Don't get me wrong, but you know what I'm saying.
Okay.
So, um, we were going to possibly experience an event that would define, um, the time as
well as the October 7th event, right?
Cause it's usually you're looking at just when Pluto crosses into the sign, but because
of the, of the, um, correlation with the, the Mars entering Aquarius, we're thinking, well,
maybe there might be another event.
And there obviously has been, right?
Um, there's been, uh, an event in, in Minnesota.
So, um, and I, I, you know, I'm sure there's other things on the news, but that's sort of dominating
U S news right now.
Um, so that's the first is, is Pluto in Aquarius.
And there are a series of, um, alignments that, uh, Pluto is going to make, or has been making
2005 through 2008, uh, with the other outer planets.
Right.
Um, one of those is the alignment that it's making with, um, with Neptune and, um, Uranus
obviously.
So, um, I know I'm a little discombobulated.
I had to shovel snow.
So any type of exertion or whatever, because of my physical condition, it, it, uh, it has
a little bit of a mental effect as well.
And I apologize for that.
Um, also I have to take like a small, but real dose of pain medicine in order to do something
like that.
So that also affects it.
So I apologize if I'm actually discombobulated.
Um, basically between now and July, uh, the first through fourth of July, we're going to
see a series of, uh, initiations, like a series of, uh, blast off moments.
Um, when Mars activates each of, each of these outer planet, um, uh, synodic, uh, conjunctions,
right.
Um, or, uh, the Saturn and Neptune synodic conjunction and the ingress of Pluto and the ingress of Uranus
into new science.
That's what Mars is going to activate.
So that happened, uh, the other day it's, um, on the April 9th or 10th, it's going to
happen, Mars is going to, um, ingress into Aries and, uh, shortly thereafter, it's going
to activate the Saturn Neptune conjunction.
So whatever we don't see happening in the world related to the conjunction on the 21st of
February or 20, you know, or 22nd, whatever, uh, we will see in April, right?
So there'll be a very visible event.
I have no doubt, very visible event.
And interestingly enough, that does correlate of course, with the whole Chris Bledsoe, April
12th, um, event related to regulus.
He said red regulus.
And then he backtracked and said, okay, it's not because regulus isn't red.
And, and then he said, it's Mars.
So we knew it was Mars because, you know, Mars is the only red thing that was going to be,
um, doing anything notable at that time.
So, uh, and then July, um, the, well, so it's like the 28th or 29th, um, Uranus will make
an, or Mars will make an ingress into Gemini activating Uranus.
Um, but on like July 1st to 2nd, um, Mars is going to conjunct, um, Uranus and that will
be explosive and what happens with these cycles, um, as far as like historically, um, I think
people sort of know this, uh, if they've paid any attention to this, like articles on
this, um, you know, Neptune in Aries and Uranus in Gemini are present in, in many of the, the
major crises, uh, historically, particularly in the U S so like Neptune was, um, present
in the beginning of Aries, uh, during the civil war and, uh, Uranus was in Gemini during the
revolution, during the civil war and during world war II, right?
So if you look at like, um, the generation theory Strauss and how every 80 years, it should
really be every 84 years.
Cause what they're talking about is, uh, Uranus when they talk about generation theory, they're
really talking about, um, uh, the, the cycle of Uranus going around the sun.
So, um, there'll be some sort of dividing event at that time.
Uh, now Pluto was in Aquarius during the revolution.
So we're actually right now experiencing, or we will be by early July, we're going to experience
all of the major outer planet astrological ingresses that have tied into, um, previous American,
uh, and world historical crises.
Um, and I think that we're looking at, right.
We're seeing this type of thing unfold.
I'll tell you, I'll give you one example.
I'm not political.
I'm not making a political statement.
And I think people should be loyal to their, their government.
Um, I'm not a rebel or whatnot.
I will say something very interesting happened.
And that is right around the time that Mars was moving into Aquarius, um, ICE announced
or the lawyers for ICE announced, sent a memo saying that they, they now believe, or is now
the policy of ICE.
I'm not, I'm not making a political statement.
I just have to keep reiterating that because people will hear it from their own political
vantage point, right.
Um, but this is, this happened.
And so they released a memo saying that, that the policy of ICE is now that they no longer
need a warrant in order to enter people's homes.
So, um, I know we have a number of people from outside the U S but, uh, for those of us from
the U S of course, that was one of the big, if not the biggest factor, um, during the period
of the revolution, right.
When you look at the declaration of independence, when you look at the constitution, um, you know,
the English were going into, um, homes without any warrants.
Uh, they were writs at the time, right.
They didn't have any writs and they were, um, busting into people's houses.
And that was a major, major factor.
So there was a huge echo and that echo wasn't when Pluto first entered Aquarius again.
Um, that echo was, uh, that was when Mars entered Aquarius, right.
But it's, it's definitely a historical echo with events, grievances around that period.
So we're, we're now at a point where some people feel they have the same grievances that
people thought they had at that period of time, regardless of what your personal position
is on it.
And I think that we'll see, um, historical echoes to, um, events from, and I, God, I hope
not.
I hope not.
I'm, I'm, I'm so dreading this.
Like this is because I, I, I've known this stuff for a long time and right.
It's like the stars are the stars.
So we've been talking about this for decades and, uh, none of us want to see the things
that happen in other countries happen in the U S and I, I don't think anyone should want
to be involved in that from any political position.
I don't think anyone should want to live through that.
Um, but I think that unfortunately it looks that way.
I mean, we're going to have to live through that, that type of stuff.
And it's, it's just, it's fucking crazy, man.
It's crazy to go from living in a country that was basically very close to paradisical.
Um, when I was young, I mean, not, it wasn't perfect.
Like people had problems, whatever, but to go to this point where we're, we're about to
willingly enter a period like that is just shocking.
Um, regardless of what people's grievances are.
So, um, yeah, we should see something very notable happen, um, in the second week of
April and, um, something very notable happen as far as like a political division or a division
of some kind in the U S in, in July.
And interestingly enough, the remote viewing, um, backs it up, right?
So, um, they're not my favorite people in the world, um, for personal reasons.
I don't think they're good people in my personal opinion, but they are good remote viewers.
Uh, the future forecasting group did a, a series of, um, videos on what they call the luminosity
event that I believe they first, they first saw on session work in 2022 or 2023.
I believe, um, certainly last year, uh, there was a large blackout in April in Europe, and
it really brought to mind the sessions that they did.
Uh, so what they predicted was a large scale crisis that would have three notable stages.
The first stage would be in April and it would be a large blackout that would affect, um, urban
areas and they predicted New York city.
And then, uh, the second stage would be in, uh, July and it would evolve a, um, political
transition in the U S again, even if, even if someone's politics lead them believe that's
a good idea.
That's not a good idea.
Um, you know, a, a sudden political transition of any kind, um, is, is not good news for the
people who live through it.
Uh, and then, um, the, the final part of that would be a, a, um, a flooding event, a coastal
flooding event, I believe on the East coast, um, in September, October.
And we've talked about this before in these spaces, there are weapons now that, um, that
are focused on creating flooding events because they avoid, um, defenses.
So, uh, obviously we hope that's not something would happen.
I'm definitely not like revealing some sort of thing that, you know, the government doesn't
know.
Right.
I mean, first of all, if we're talking about something online, the government knows it.
Um, but remote viewers have been seeing this for years.
They've seen some sort of man-made object, um, in the, into the ocean and create a, uh,
a flooding event.
So we hope to God that the, the, the U S has amazing resources.
I mean, resources that are like science fiction.
And so, you know, when I was growing up, like I, I, I definitely was part of, like, I was
someone who was a sort of a reaction to the baby boomers and the baby boomers tend to have
this, or, or, or tended to have this, um, this feeling that the government was like an
omnipotent parent.
And so they, they really, by the time the cold war ended, did not take, uh, the possibility
of any other country having any power over or influence over us very seriously, at least
none that I know.
Um, and tended to adopt this vision.
Like everything that was going on in the world was stage managed by the U S right.
Like other countries were stage managed by us and everything was a show, uh, run by
one omnipotent government and, and none of the conflict that you would see was real.
And it wasn't just like conspiracy people.
It was like normal people, um, who held that belief, uh, like average, but not normal, you
know, average people who held that belief, um, for a long time after the fall of the cold
war.
And some of them still do, and they don't take the geopolitical situation seriously at
all, uh, because they don't believe that it's real.
They think it's being stage managed to advance, uh, domestic U S political, um, positions.
Like the whole world is being controlled by the U S in order to, according to this theory,
in order to manipulate domestic U S politics.
I've always thought it was, uh, crazy.
However, uh, what I did learn in 2024, uh, was just how, and not from on the inside, from
the outside, like just how amazing the capabilities of our government of this government are.
So you hear like this thing about Venezuela, right?
They went in there with some sort of like, there's there, they're bragging about the
discombobulator.
I mean, they have, we know that in the remote viewing circles, people have talked about for
years, and I'm not saying this is true.
I'm saying what people have talked about remote viewing circles for years, since the nineties,
the government has a computer that can see the future, right?
Like a computer that can remote view the future.
No, I, I'm not saying it's true.
I'm not saying it's false.
I'm saying that's what people say.
Um, and people who may have, um, may be in a position to know, right?
Rather than conjecture, whatever it is that the government has, like it's, it's kind of
crazy to bet against them.
And so you would think if remote viewers all over the place is seeing this event, perhaps,
right?
Perhaps it won't happen.
Perhaps like their, their abilities are, are there, their resources are so great.
They can stop that from happening.
And I think that would be a great thing.
So, um, yeah, I just wanted to mention that as far as the astrology is concerned, that's
why we're seeing this sudden acceleration.
We're going to see an acceleration in at least three stages, uh, going forward.
We're also going to see an acceleration, um, in, uh, prior to the Saturn-Neption conjunction
on the 20th, because we have an eclipse right before that, right?
And that eclipse is actually, that eclipse is going to, um, or potentially could, um, have
an effect on the, um, divisive nature of, um, Uranus Ingress into Gemini.
So the eclipse is going to be in Aquarius, uh, it's going to be square.
Am I screwing up here in Pisces area?
So, uh, yeah, it's going to be square the, um, the Ingress, um, so like for UFOX, for
instance, um, because UFOX has natal Mars at like 129, one, one, one degree in 29 minutes
of, um, of Gemini, uh, that eclipse, uh, I think it's very likely that someone who's
a prominent figure in UFOX will, will leave the scene, uh, hopefully in, um, completely
like gentle, peaceful, like maybe go off and find a new hobby, but like someone who, a prominent
male figure in, in UFOX is probably going to be, you know, no longer active in UFOX, right?
Or ufology.
Um, and that, uh, that Gemini Ingress into, or is that Uranus Ingress into Gemini, um, is
going to have a, um, polarizing effect both in the U.S. and, um, in the world.
So the U.S. is particularly, uh, affected by these, um, these outer planet, uh, alignments
and transits right now, because our, I see the point in the natal chart that is related
to a nation, the homeland and the people, right?
But in your chart, it will be your family, uh, and home.
Uh, that is, um, that point is, uh, going to be directly activated by the Saturn, uh, Neptune
conjunction on the 20th.
And so, because there's an alignment between the, these three outer planets at that time,
right?
It's also going to be affected by Uranus.
It's also going to be affected by Pluto.
So all of these things that are going on are focused on that point.
And I think that, um, right, the Saturn-Neptune conjunction is going to be at, uh, 40 minutes
Aries.
So zero 40 minutes Aries.
And our natal IC is at one degree.
So it's almost exact.
It's incredibly close.
And, uh, the Aries point is the point that represents the ascendant of reality and global
civilization, which is why the U S like you could tell from the Sibley chart, the chart
that most of us use for the U S like you could tell that, um, the, the way that Americans
sort of view the world as part of the American family, like, you know, the whole world is, is
America.
That's that reason.
Right.
Because our, I see is that point and the way that we've sort of like filled up global
culture, that's all because of that, that point.
Um, and so whatever crisis is, you know, unfortunately coming, right.
It's going to disproportionately affect the U S at least at first.
And I don't think anything can affect the U S and not affect the rest of the world.
So, uh, cause we're so deeply tied into everything.
Yeah.
So, um, yeah, uh, February, uh, 17th to like the 21st or 22nd.
Um, and then, uh, you know, July 1st, right around that time.
Um, and April 9th through 12th, like those are periods where we're going to see major developments
and major acceleration.
Um, and I just wanted to mention that, uh, because I've talked about this in a number
of spaces and, you know, like I said, the, the crowd that I, I drew sort of accidentally
was a conspiratainment crowd and because they're focused on the entertainment value of these
subjects, right.
They just kind of laugh off that stuff.
So, you know, all the time I'm, I'm talking to other people who are sort of a part of that
UFO X community, although I'm not.
And I'm saying, well, what do you think about this now?
And they don't really respond, right?
Because all of these things that are happening, we spoke about in spaces six months ago, nine
months ago, and, uh, at that time, they didn't take it very seriously.
Now what's happening, if someone isn't interested in astrology or if they're an aspiring influencer
and they're interested in their own influence, but not in other people's influence, right?
They don't want other people to have influence because they want to, uh, build their own cred.
Well, they just sort of ignore it when other people are, are vindicated.
This isn't the type of thing you want to be vindicated about though, right?
So, um, what is the other side, right?
So I, I, I talked last time I said, you know, the other side is, uh, we're looking at, uh,
uh, potential spiritual revolution and that's not just, um, Saturn and Neptune.
It is, uh, Neptune and Aries, but it's also, um, it's also Pluto and Aquarius and, um, to a
lesser degree Uranus and Gemini.
So, uh, Pluto and Aquarius and, uh, Neptune and Aries are both crusading, um, periods.
That's not necessarily good.
Like religious wars, crusading wars aren't, aren't good.
It's not something we want to live through.
So, um, on the other hand, these are also periods where, uh, new religious information
or new spiritual information is released.
Um, and, uh, new, not necessarily new faiths.
They can be, uh, but, you know, innovations within faiths and, you know, new spiritual teachings,
they spread, right?
So, just like you can have a, a militaristic crusade, uh, you can have a charitable crusade.
You can have a, um, you can have a great awakening period.
Um, you could have a, uh, Christian revival.
Um, all of those fit into the, the basic Neptune and Aries, um, spiritual slash military expansion
crusading period.
When it comes to the Archons and, uh, right, the intuitive underground material, which, as
we've said from the very beginning, ties in directly to, um, material going back to Zoroaster,
right?
So, starting from Zoroaster and coming forward, every clairvoyant community, every clairvoyant
movement, when they've looked into the nature of reality, has seen the same thing.
And they've, they've recorded it in different ways.
Sometimes it's recorded, um, using the esoteric code speak to avoid religious persecution at
the time, right?
So, um, prior to the, um, prior to the, uh, dominance of Christian orthodoxy, if you go
back to the 200 years following, uh, the life of Jesus, for most of the, that two to 300 year
period, um, what we now refer to as Gnostics, they did not refer to themselves as Gnostics.
They referred to themselves as Christians and they were, um, the Orthodox Christians, um,
or what later became the Orthodoxy in Christianity branded them Gnostics in order to other them,
right?
As part of their, um, movement to expel them from Christianity and sort of become the dominant
force.
However, for most of that period, they outnumbered the, what would we would consider Orthodox Christians
10 to 1, right?
For hundreds of years after the, after the death of Christ, um, Christians that held Gnostic
viewpoints outnumbered Christians that hold Orthodox viewpoints 10 to 1.
And they can tell that they've historically had both the writings.
They also have the graves of the individuals involved.
Like there's, there's a strong evidence that it's not like a conjecture.
It's not like a, um, a talking point to support, um, to support a personal agenda.
Like I said, they didn't consider themselves to be Gnostic.
Like if you associate them with the ideas that people spread around now and call Gnosticism,
they, they wouldn't enjoy that.
That wouldn't be how they looked at themselves.
And that isn't what they believed.
Uh, we do have now since the, uh, the forties and fifties, we do have copies of the books of
what they believed.
Um, and we have like, um, a timeline, right?
And the first one we think on the timeline is the Apophricon of John.
However, um, the Gnostic, um, what we now call the, the Gnostic teachings, um, are, are
in outgrowth of whatever was happening at the very beginning of Christianity.
Um, and they correlate strongly to the teachings of Paul and John in the New Testament.
So when people say like, falsely try to say that like Gnosticism was a foreign religion
grafted on Christianity, it's just not true, right?
It's, it's very clearly associated with, um, Pauline teachings and the, the John, the apostle.
Um, very clearly there from the very beginning.
Uh, however, the book that talks about like talks in full about this, what we would now
consider the reality overlay, what other people call like the matrix simulation, like that's
the Apophricon of John.
And that, that was right around the same time, maybe 50 years later, we're right around the
same time.
Um, so that was, uh, uh, at that time around the time of Christ to 300 years later, this
was like a commonly discussed idea.
This was not like, um, a persecuted idea.
It was, I mean, I'm sure they were persecuted, but they were persecuted no more than any other
religious dissenters, right?
It wasn't like a focus, like the focus of persecution wasn't on eliminating this idea.
And then once it was, there was another religion, which, or another, um, Clairvon movement, which
revealed the same thing, right?
Manny and Manichaeanism, which said like, okay, um, these Orthodox Catholics are trying
to crush like these true teachings.
We're going to, you know, revive them and spread them through the Persian empire and China.
And Manichaeanism was around for a couple hundred years as well.
So in antiquity, this whole like matrix simulation, reality overlay was a very commonly understood
principle.
And it was what the Greeks believed, what the Hindus believed, it was what the Buddhists
believed.
And it was what many people consider themselves to be Christian believed.
And you find that like coming forward, every single clairvoyant, uh, movement says that
same thing.
But we're at a point in time where, um, this isn't what people all often, I'm sure all
of you have heard this, like, uh, probably for years, probably for your entire lives.
Like, Oh, there's a great awakening on taking place.
You know, um, this, this isn't just like in the new age and in the paranormal, right?
Cause this is something that, that, that mainstream Orthodox, ultra Orthodox Christianity goes through
where like Christian teachers come out like every other year and like, Oh, a great awakening
is under place.
Right.
And they shut down all the churches in the country and like, Oh, this is a great awakening.
And, um, you know, all the Iranians are turning into Christians and it's, it's not, I'm not
calling any specific individual liar.
Um, but it's, it's, it's, it's never true.
Um, what we see is up or until very recently, we've seen diminishing interest in, in, uh,
Christianity, but also, um, these new age great awakenings tend to be, uh, just trying to think
of, uh, just the, not, it's not real.
Um, it's just hype.
Uh, it's a marketing, um, gimmick.
We did have, um, what would be considered, what I would consider to be awakening, um, in the nineties.
Um, and so the, um, the period where this, this wave of awakening began, um, I can tell you
exactly when it began again in, uh, in April of 1993 from February to April, 1993.
Right.
And so it was the, um, conjunction of Uranus and Neptune, uh, mystic revolution.
And, uh, when you date these things, you can date them from their synonic conjunction,
but you often, if you're looking historically, you date them from the eclipse that occurs
after the, um, synonic conjunction because the eclipses represents new beginnings, right?
Um, but it was 1993.
And if, if those of us who were alive at that time in the U S remember it was, it was very
different and I'm sure it was different everywhere else in the world as well.
Um, but I often think about like how much, like we've, we've, we've, we've, we've
we've gained a lot in affluence and tech and doodads and shit, but we've lost a lot of
the, the spirit that I mean, there were all kinds of new age bookstores and coffee shops
and communities around at that time that have sort of fizzled out now.
I'm not saying any one of those was, was particularly valid because of course, um, Neptune is involved.
So there was a tremendous amount of delusion, but those were individuals responding to the
impulse of mystical revolution coming through the collective unconscious.
What, what happened, what went wrong, uh, were those individuals who were involved in,
and I was one.
Um, and I, I, I don't want to take personal responsibility for this, right?
Because I don't think I was in this boat, but the majority of people I knew who were involved
in that in one way or the other, the way they received that event was as a personal anointing
that they themselves were some special in some way.
They themselves had something unique to offer that others didn't.
And so within a few years, there was a fracturing that really, um, accelerated, uh, after 9-11.
But there was a brief period there where there was a very real energy, um, of awakening in the world.
And one argument that's been made in esoteric communities since 9-11 is that 9-11, the, the esoteric
significance or motivation behind 9-11 was to, um, sabotage that wave of awakening, uh, in the world.
And if you look back at it, it's definitely true that, um, that we, we were, that was a big turning
point for us, right?
And things have, uh, things have gone in a very different direction ever since.
So I think it's, there's a validity to the idea that, um, the events around 9-11 were in some
sense, esoterically, uh, designed to disempower that, that wave of awakening.
Um, now we're in this period, as I was saying, we're, we're, we're seeing this alignment, right?
Heading into this year, we know this in astrology is Barbolts Basket.
It's not the best name, but it's a, a three-year period.
We're going to see this, this lesser trine, this lesser grand trine.
So we're going to see a relationship between the three outer planets.
And, uh, at one point, Jupiter and Saturn are involved as well.
So it's actually 5.3, um, at different times.
So, uh, there's been a tremendous debate.
Historically, astrologers have seen this as a very good thing.
And I think that, um, those of us who are now closer to this event do not see it necessarily
as a good thing.
But one of the impulses in this series of astrological events, um, is, is the awakening impulse.
When we get into the discussion of like, what do we have to do in order to escape?
Like it, okay.
If it's true that this world is somewhat of an illusion, if it's true that, uh, at the conclusion
of our lives, um, we are recycled in some sense, which is the, um, the idea that, um, remote viewers
who've looked at this subject have come up with, it's also the idea that people had, you know,
in these, in these past, uh, clairvoyant communities, right?
That after you die, um, you're, so they would say reincarnated, but it's not really reincarnation
because you go through a period where basically, um, you're torn up in a metaphorical sense
and recycled.
So your, some aspect of you is reincarnated, but the, um, the personality is destroyed.
Um, let's just, let's just go on the assumption.
This is true, right?
Cause that's what the, our spaces were about, uh, early on.
So the idea they were looking into, intuitive on the ground was looking into moksha and moksha
is, is like Hindu nirvana.
Although nirvana is like the cessation of consciousness, like a final cessation of consciousness and moksha,
uh, um, I don't know, they, they, they did some Hindu stuff.
I'm not really sure why, because they're like Canadians and like middle Americans,
but one of them must've been really into like pop Hinduism or something.
Cause they did a bunch of session work on, on Hindu, uh, topics where they looked into moksha
liberation and Hindu religion, the remote viewing.
And, uh, they came up with, um, this, uh, okay.
So they also did a session.
What's the most important thing remote viewing can look into.
And when they, that's not the exact phrasing.
So I don't want them, I don't want to misrepresent them, but that's the gist of what the phrasing
was.
And, um, that is when they, uh, got this whole thing about the light and, um, the tunnel of
light that you experienced after you die being a trap, which other remote viewers have seen
as well.
Right.
And it's become sort of a cliche and, uh, and a, um,
a distraction, um, people debating this one point.
But the basic idea is, is that after we die, um, whatever remains of us is trapped in some
way.
And the idea is, how do you get out?
And so they, when they looked into moksha, they weren't expecting to find more information
about, um, escaping from this process, but they did.
And, um, the moksha was escaping from the reality overlay and returning to the, the, I'm going
to call it the well of souls.
Um, all right.
So in antiquity, uh, after you died, um, you had to, uh, they call the aerial toll houses
in Christianity, right?
Originally.
So the Orthodox church still has aerial toll houses.
Uh, very few people in the Orthodox church still believe it, but it's still an official
teaching.
It was originally a teaching in all Orthodox Christianity.
And it comes from, uh, Gnosticism and it comes from Hermeticism, which was the pagan version
of Gnosticism at the time.
And so what a person believed, um, 50 AD, what a person in, in the Roman empire believed
in 50 AD, uh, or most of them believed was that after you died, you had to ascend or your
soul would ascend, um, through the spheres, the heavens in Judaism, um, from planet to planet
and would meet the archons, the rulers of the heavenly spheres.
And you would have to, um, convince them to let you through.
And your goal would be to get out of this solar system and back to the fixed stars.
So out into the universe, uh, because they believe we were trapped in this solar system.
It was like a gravity well, right?
That's what we're looking at now, the gravity well of the solar system, right?
They were trapped in this, uh, this well.
And, um, the remote viewers, when they were looking at it, they saw a pit.
So it says this pit with levels, um, that you would have to ascend.
And I think it was metaphorical, right?
Um, another way that some remote viewers see it and also the historical, the Gnostics and
other clairvoyants see it is like, instead of the planets being out there in the solar system,
they're all here, like different levels, like vibrations, right?
Speaking of the nineties and the mystic revolution, the Celestine prophecy, the, the, the Celestine
prophecies was a fictional series of books that began the whole, um, mystical revolution,
the whole synchronicity movement.
So, um, the idea was that you would ascend like levels of vibration after your death.
Um, and in ancient times they had, uh, spells, right?
So, uh, you would try to obviously perfect yourself as much as you could as a person.
Um, but that wasn't going to work.
So you had to have these spells that you would memorize.
And when you would go from planet to planet, you would have to tell like the Archon on Mars,
uh, you know, a certain set of, um, I guess as a spell, right?
A certain set of, um, phrases or whatever.
And then he would let you go and you went to the next one, you use a different spell.
Uh, I'm dubious as to, um, I'm dubious to the idea that that, uh, worked.
Um, so what the Christians originally believed, what Christians originally believed, you know,
like I said, this is still in, um, it's still in orthodoxy, uh, was that, uh, for Christian
would be escorted by angels.
So you wouldn't need a spell because the angels would be with you and the angels would compel
the Archon to let you go.
So a Christian would still have to go up through, um, you know, you go from earth to the moon
and from the moon to, I believe, Mercury, and then you'd go to the sun.
I don't know why Mercury, then the sun, um, you have to ask them.
And then you go to Venus, you go to Mars and Jupiter, Saturn, and then you get out, right?
And so a Christian would, wouldn't have to worry about knowing the spells because you'd
have the angels with you.
That was originally how it worked.
Um, and row viewing doesn't have the angels and it doesn't have the spells, but it has people
ascending up those levels if you can get out of the reality of the plane.
Now, from the perspective of the remote viewers, what happened was, and also the esoteric communities
since Gnostics started, right?
Um, that, that was the original process.
And then, um, the Archons caught us and they imprisoned us.
And so originally there were seven spheres, but then they constructed an artificial sphere called
the eighth sphere.
And they, this is found in esoteric Buddhism as well, which is how it wound up in theosophy
in the 1800s.
The eighth sphere is an artificial sphere.
It's a matrix.
It's a simulation.
It's a reality overlay.
And that's where we are.
According to all of these esoteric traditions, right?
They say it in different ways.
They have different taboos around it.
But when you penetrate to the root of what they're saying, uh, that is what you find.
And in order to get out of that, um, the remote viewers, when they looked into it, Intuitive
Underground, they, the first thing they said is, right?
And other remote viewers as well, don't go into the light.
Well, it's sort of a compulsion.
It's not really something you can control.
Uh, and when I first started talking to Morgan, he's like, I'm not coming back here.
Like, what are you talking about?
He's like, I'm not coming back to this world.
Um, when I, when I die, um, this is my last reincarnation.
I was like, hey, great, man.
Um, you should tell other people about this though, right?
Because we're all, we're all sort of screwed if you're right.
So you should tell other people.
Um, and that's where we, we began.
And by the time we finally made it to the space and got everything in order, we had discovered
that the original material had been a little bit more complicated than that.
That it wasn't just don't go into the light.
That it was, you don't go into the light and then you go through some sort of interrogation
process or a courtroom.
Now, if you're familiar with antiquity, what they believed, um, you know, aside from the
people who believed you'd go from planet to planet, right?
There were those who believed you would stand trial, right?
So in Zoroastrianism or in Egyptian mythology, right?
You would have a weighing of your heart.
It would stand, uh, in a sense, you would have to stand trial for your actions, um, in this
world.
And then they would let you go through if you passed that point.
So that was in the session data as well, but the remote viewers saw it and they said it
was, um, it was a corrupt process.
So basically I think that when you look into the, the, the sum of the remote viewing data
on the subject that I'm aware of, uh, it's very difficult.
Um, if this is, if this is accurate, it's very difficult to, to get out, to escape the archons
and, uh, reality overlay.
And it's like, there's a series of steps.
And like, if you get through one, they try to get you on the next one.
Right.
So when I, when we were formulating these, these, cause it's right.
It's their data that I intuitive underground data, but they didn't know anything about the
esoteric traditions.
They didn't know anything about the Gnostics or whatever.
So it wasn't until I started talking to them that we realized that the connection between
all of this material, right?
Cause it was, when you said, look, this stuff that you've, you printed out here on the website,
intuitive underground.com.
I said, the stuff that you have on this website, this is like straight out of Gnostic texts.
This is straight out of esoteric Buddhism.
This is straight out of these ancient traditions.
And they didn't know that.
Or at least as far as we know, they didn't know that.
And I have reason to believe that's true.
That's, uh, remote viewers don't tend to be well-read on the esoteric.
Let's just put it like that.
So, um, where we sort of parted ways was, I think the best that they could think of to
do was to teach people remote viewing.
So this is the argument.
Ingo Swann said, um, that when you die, um, you lose access to your physical senses.
If you don't have, if you haven't trained your psychic abilities, then you go to sleep
for a while.
You enter a period of darkness.
And this is sort of like, I think we see behind this in, in ancient traditions as well.
Uh, that you would sort of, um, go into this period of darkness.
You wouldn't have any sensory input at all.
You would fall asleep.
And then you would, your soul would sort of wait there.
I think Ingo says you're there in like a cocoon or something, right?
Like, like, like if you walked into a mortuary, like piles of, I don't know, sleeping souls
or something, um, until your psychic faculties awaken.
Because you have to have sensory perception, right?
You have to have perception, extra sensory perception once you're out of the body.
And so their perspective was, well, the best we can do is teach people.
And I think by we, I mean like them, right?
The best they can do is, is, is teach people, um, remote viewing to give people that awareness
awareness, uh, after they die.
And hopefully that awareness would forestall falling into the reincarnation trap, right?
And again, this is, these aren't my concepts.
These are other people's concepts.
Uh, the problem with that is that there is a, a difference between awareness and awakening.
And this is where we all, this is, everything has been weaving to this moment.
Remote viewing is, uh, and, and, and, and astrology, right?
They're, they're both, um, they're both disciplines that can give you a tremendous amount of awareness.
I mean, literally what remote viewing is, is giving you extra sensory awareness of things
that you'll never, you would never have any other contact with, right?
And astrology is an, is an analog simulation model.
And it gives you, um, the ability to consciously perceive patterns in human interaction and relationships
that you are incapable of directly perceiving.
And so if you don't study astrology, um, no one, unless someone studies astrology,
they are incapable of having any perception of these patterns that rule their lives.
That's true.
That's a fact.
Um, so both of these modalities, you know, can impart a tremendous awareness in individuals.
And if you're an expert in a modality related to awareness, and you're confronted with this problem,
right, then the problem seems like an awareness problem.
Like, well, we pass on and the afterlife isn't what we'd like it to be.
And the reason is because we're not aware.
And so because we're not aware, we're not capable of making choices, right?
We leave the body.
We're not aware.
We see a tunnel of light.
It's sucking us, right?
And we just let go and get sucked into the tunnel.
Or we leave the body and we don't have any extrasensory abilities.
And so we, we fall asleep.
And, you know, apparently you were lying there like a rock in, you know, piled up in the
mortuary or wherever in the hospitals.
Right.
And that, okay.
So I'm saying that and it sounds like I'm being sarcastic, but that's actually something
Ingo said, right?
Ingo said, if you could see what was going on in these hospitals, you would see stacked
up basically rocks that are people's, whatever's left of a person after their life.
And that is, uh, an idea that you find in some Eastern occult teachings, not far Eastern,
but like caucus area and Iran and Russia, like occult teachings of that stream.
Um, that's something that you find there as well, that idea, right?
That, uh, once you're dead, you become a stone.
Okay.
So we walk through life and we are sleepwalkers.
And that is the first and most difficult thing for people to understand that the majority
of what you do on a day-to-day basis is a conditioned series of reactions to external stimulus.
Um, we have, uh, a indirection, uh, programed into our mind.
We have a, a filter that leads us to believe that we, we consciously will ourselves to do
things.
We, that we, that we make these decisions, right?
We are the origin of our thoughts.
We are the origin of our decisions.
Um, but even, you know, getting aside from neurology, like, I mean, sorry, aside from
the esoteric, even neurologists know this isn't true, right?
So they can, they can look at a brain, they can see activity in the brain.
Prior to a person making a decision or having a thought, and they can have a, an idea of
what that decision or thought will be prior to the individual themselves, right?
So your, your thoughts, your thinking do not, does not determine your actions.
It explains them.
And if you, we've all had the experience of driving and you're driving down the street,
or I think we all have, right.
And, uh, you drive someplace, um, every day and you just start blacking out, right?
Well, you're not like blacked out, blacked out, but you don't remember anything because you're
going to autopilot.
And so you're driving down the street, but you're, you're daydreaming.
And so aside from the, like the, um, the idea that we're like, with the origin of our thoughts
is our conscious mind.
And then our conscious mind is directing our actions when that's not true.
It's just rationalizing them or explaining them.
You know, the rest of the time we spend daydreaming and, um, all kinds of psychological processes,
you know, cognitive biases and projection.
And when you get into just analyzing even people's interactions with each other, even
when they're not daydreaming, right.
Um, you can get a group of people can have interactions with each other and they, they
have different stories about what happened, right?
Like I have to say, you know, I, I've known Morgan for a couple of years now.
Right.
But I have to say, look, I don't want to misrepresent him when I'm talking about conversations
he and I had, because, you know, even if they're in writing, we can both look at the writing
and interpret it differently.
Right.
Um, that's the power of mind to, to project meaning onto things.
And because we're daydreaming most of the time, we're projecting daydream, like meaning
onto things in false narratives.
And so our, our memories aren't very accurate if they're accurate at all.
Like our perception of, of our lives is, is not very accurate.
If it's accurate at all, we are not largely, we are not awake.
Largely we are lucid, right.
And we are lucidly interpreting information that we're receiving from the collective and
individual unconscious.
So these, these messages are coming through from ourselves and from the collective unconscious
unconscious in the form of synchronicities, in the form of archetypes emerging around us
and, um, and dreams.
And, uh, we interpret those through the, the, the social filter.
You know, some of it, a lot of it gets filtered out.
Right.
Um, and we interpret it through the, like when we're analyzing or talking about it, where we're,
we're constantly editing, um, even those, those, that's that, you know, the small amount that
we understand of our world in order to fit in with other people, what we perceive to be
other people's perceptions of the world so that, you know, we don't stand out.
Right.
And, um, and so that we're not in danger, we're not marginalized, right.
Which is a, a metaphor for being pushed to the edge of a social network, right.
Where you have like a, a town as your, as your metaphor and in a town or in a, in a, in a, in a human
settlement, right.
The, the, the more marginal individual is the, they're actually living on the margins of the
settlement, which means the most likely to get a, you know, eaten by a, by a lion or bitten
by a snake or, you know, killed by invaders.
I don't want to be marginalized where this is a strong social instinct is, is, is, is, you
know, socialization is an instinct in most people, right.
So it's not in their control and that leads us to edit even the small understanding of
our lives that we have to fit in with other people.
So, uh, barely lucid would be the best way to explain, uh, life, even for a person who
believes that they're very aware, uh, even if for a very spiritual person, even for a meditator,
even, you know, especially, uh, no offense, Sally, uh, but especially in the astrology community,
no offense, Lou, in the, in the remote viewing community, in the communities where people
believe that they have, um, or have reason to believe they have greater awareness.
Um, they can often have less lucidity than other people, right.
Uh, it's like a reaction or the, the awareness that they have becomes hypnotic, right.
People can hypnotize themselves back into the trance state, back into the, the walking daydream.
If that is our life.
And if we can wake up every day for 50 to a hundred years and go through the same interactions
and run into the same shit, right.
We can fail in the same ways.
I mean, some of us succeed in the same ways.
That's great.
Right.
But like for people who are successful, what do they tell you?
Success is a habit, right?
That's, that's, that's what they say.
And it's because it's true.
Right.
So they have, they're habitually successful.
Some of us are habitual, habitual failures, right.
But these are, these are things that are happening to us.
Um, and we're barely conscious during the process.
So if you can do that every day of your life for 50 to a hundred years, uh, what is going
to happen when you pass on and if having a greater awareness, whether it's greater insight, right.
So this, there are different levels of squeeze.
So on a material level, it could be just like, you know, secrets that other people don't know.
Like, uh, um, someone who works for the government has greater awareness than someone who doesn't.
Someone who works in the intelligence industry has greater awareness than someone who works
in the government.
Right.
Um, a psychologist has greater awareness than a person who is not a psychologist.
Uh, so we could make that argument for sociologists, although that's not my favorite thing.
Anthropology, that's certainly the case, right?
A meditator has greater awareness than someone who doesn't meditate.
Okay.
We, we still live largely conditioned lives.
And if death is a process and that process takes us a place where we don't want to be.
Right.
And that's, again, that's the presupposition of this argument.
I'm not saying it's true.
I'm not saying it's not saying this is, this is when we talk about the archons, when we talk
about the afterlife and, you know, the reality overlay and all these, these topics, right.
What's a, is a thinking exercise.
Um, you, you, you, you're going to pass on and regardless of the level of awareness you have,
if you're not awake, what difference does it make?
If you're not awake, you're not making your own decisions.
And so historically, when you get involved in the esoteric, right, you, you aren't right.
The new age is about awareness.
Okay.
In our consumer oriented society, awareness is a, is a, is a, is an assumption pattern.
Right.
But you can't sell awakening.
You can't market it.
Can't, you know, you can't create a community of waking.
You can create a community from awakening individuals, but it's, it's not something that you can manage externally.
Right.
It's something that, that, that, that occurs inside an individual and, and outside the individual
at the same time.
Right.
So my argument with them was we have to look back at these, the teachings of these past communities
and what did they say?
Right.
So it's not just like, what does a modern remote viewer say about what he sees about how
to navigate the afterlife?
Right.
So it's one clairvoyant at one point in history.
Well, what did the great movements of other clairvoyants say?
We're going to, we're going to look at this direct perception.
Right.
And they all said the same thing.
They all said you had to make changes in your life while you're alive.
Right.
So they were like the, the teachings of the common person, which said like, okay, memorize a bunch
of spells.
And I wish that was, you know, cause it's so alien to our current understanding.
Believe, believe me, when you look at, this is something like anyone who, um, when you get
texts from the ancient texts from the ancient world, they're filled with magical spells.
I know that sounds strange, but it's absolutely true.
It was a massive preoccupation in antiquity.
And to the extent that like, you know, Greek cookbooks and shit have spells written in the
margins.
It was, they just lived in a very different way than we do.
Right.
And a different, different experience of reality.
So the Hoi Ploi would learn, you know, would memorize spells, lines to tell the, the gatekeepers
after they passed away in antiquity.
And that, that would get them through.
I think we would all agree it probably wasn't true.
Right.
Um, but the people who were involved in the mysteries and the esoteric, um, both pagan
and, you know, in the Judeo Christian world, right.
They would focus on, on letting go of the negative patterns of interacting with other
people, right.
They would let go of the influence of these planets or archons.
You know, if you were pagan, you were letting go of the archons as planets, like we astrologers
would talk about.
And if you were in the Judeo Christian world, you would be letting go of the influence of
the archon, the individual, you know, pagan God that represented the planet.
Right.
But you would be Venus represents the illusion of longing.
Okay.
So, uh, the average person would, would memorize lines to tell Venus after he died, to try to
get through to, to heaven and, um, you know, the initiate would, would try to overcome the
illusion of longing while they were alive.
So they didn't have that tether, that chain holding them right here.
That karma as well, because the karma is the consequence of an action, right.
Karma is ruled by Saturn.
Karma is the crystallization of consequence into, right.
Cause that's, that's really what Saturn, I mean, it governs other things, right.
So Saturn from the ancient perspective, um, Saturn was, uh, the evil machinations that lie
an ambush, Saturn was the things that trap us and the ways that we trap others for our own
benefit.
Right.
And so you look at the things that if anyone here is into astrology, you know, Sally is,
if you look at the things that Saturn represents that we look from like a modern, um, like our
modern perspective, we say, Oh, it represents time.
Well, yeah, time is a trap, you know, represents, um, some type of authority.
Well, that's, it looked at authority as a trap.
Well, it represents, um, cause it also represented, uh, Saturn represents, uh, the cultivation of
grain, right.
It represents agriculture, right.
Saturn was the God of agriculture.
Well, how does that relate to time?
How does it, well, because agriculture was also a trap.
People were free.
Now they, life was not easy, but people were off doing their own thing.
They had no authority over them except for, you know, the strongest person around them
could compel them to do things.
Right.
But they could run away.
But once, you know, people embraced agriculture, they got a benefit from it, but it was also
a trap.
Right.
And it, it, it, uh, it was an ambush.
So, um, those things in life that, um, that seem like they're, well, just, just, just
the, the ways that people ambush each other, right.
That's Saturnine behavior, the ways that people set snares for each other.
Um, and so karma is the crystallite, cause that's Saturn is a crystallizing force.
It is the, uh, crystallization of the consequences of our actions into what Jung would say, would
say that, um, when you don't address, um, when you don't address the forces inside of
you, right.
Your, like your negative inclinations, your iconic patterns of behavior, he wouldn't say
iconic patterns of behavior, but that's what he meant.
Right.
You will experience them as fate, you know, from, from outside of yourself, you'll experience
them in your interactions with others in the world around you as fate.
And so that's what karma is.
Karma is the crystallization of the consequences of these unaddressed patterns of behavior that
we experience as events around us.
Um, so what my argument was, was that we had to do that, right.
We have to do what the ancients said and, um, what in early Christianity, right.
We all, well, those of us who have grown up in Judeo Christian, what the jail Christian milieu
or whatever, you know, I've heard this, you know, you have to die, right.
And before you die, right.
So you have to, um, if you love life onto, you know, don't, uh, I mean, I'm of course screwing
up the, oh, now I sound like I haven't read the Bible.
So, you know, if you, if you, um, don't love life onto death or whatever, so you can't,
um, you have to begin these changes while you're alive.
You have to wake up while you're alive.
Basically it's, it's not the terms they use.
Right.
But that's what they're basically talking about is that you can't, you can't love the
illusion of life, um, until you physically die and expect that, um, once you die, you're
going to, right.
You're just going to, um, uh, get out, you know, go to heaven, go to whatever, wherever.
Right.
So a modern Orthodox person would say, you go to hell.
Um, you know, the, you know, way back in the day, they would say that you got recycled
and reincarnated.
So the Hindus and Buddhists would also say, and actually the Mesoamericans as well, which
is funny.
Uh, you don't hear that very often, but it is apparently true.
Um, you, you have to not just become aware, you have to become awake.
And that's my position.
It's not the position held by, um, remote viewers that I've worked with.
Right.
And remote viewers can be very aware.
They can have tremendous awareness.
Just like astrologists can, just like ufologists can, experiences can, right.
Have levels of awareness that other people can't achieve or even imagine, but it doesn't mean
you're awake and you have to awake.
Right.
And, and part of that, right.
Is, and this is what I, the trouble I ran into, um, what people will say is, well, look,
um, you know, it's that old gambling thing.
Like the game may be fixed, but this is the only game in town.
Like, this is the only life I have.
That's what you have people say.
You have to say, this is the only life I have.
Yeah.
I mean, these things may be true.
This, you know, perhaps after we die, you know, bad things happen to us.
And, but this is the only life that we have.
Well, that's exactly the opposite of what an early Christian would have said.
Uh, it's the opposite of what a Buddhist would, would say, or, you know, a traditional
religious Hindu would say, which is you have to give up all that.
Now, right.
While you're still having the beginning of the process is to say, look, this isn't real.
This is real in some sense.
It isn't real in others.
This isn't the life that I have.
This is a trap, right?
This is a trap where, um, I live in a world that encourages me to, uh, take advantage of
other people, um, to behave in a harmful way towards others in order for my own benefit
and to live.
And then, you know, when I'm done here, when I want to be free, I have to face the, the
consequences for the things that I've done.
Right.
And they're going to, if you're orthodox, they're going to send you to hell.
And if you're, you know, if you're Gnostically inspired or Buddhist or a Hindu, right.
You're going to believe that you're going to get recycled and you have to work on your
karma in another life.
Well, that is that working on the karma is overcoming the pattern, right?
As you never, you're never going to get to, um, like keeping score, right?
You're never going to get to the point where like you keep score on one side and all the
good things on one side, cancel all the bad things on the other side, because in order
to get through life, right?
If you have these arconic traits still inside of you, like you're going to keep behaving that
way.
Okay.
So it's just, it's just not possible to do that.
Like you have to address the root issue, you know, and the root issue are according to
the ancients, like the root issues are, um, um, cycles of increase or decrease, which is
what the moon represented, which is inconstancy, right?
The belief in, the belief in, it's very, this is.
So it's a difficult one.
I think I have a blind spot because it's always difficult for me to talk about, um, you know,
when you get into like Gnosticism or like what the, um, what the remote viewers say, like
the moon plays a particularly strong role.
Um, you find this in like Gurdjieff teachings as well, uh, where he said, you know, um, human
beings are food for the moon.
So the esoteric teacher Gurdjieff said, uh, we have those like cycles, right?
Like the eclipses and lunar cycles, full moon.
And, and we have like tides and we have like a tide in the affairs of people as well.
And that increase and decrease, I think is tied to like the ambition to change your circumstances.
So it's a very difficult one to understand, like, especially as a modern person to accept,
right?
Like that, the first thing you have to do is, is release the attachment to the idea that,
you know, not only do you want your life to change, but that life should change.
That's really tough.
So it's a tough one to even talk about.
Right.
And so, um, you know, Mercury is the, is evil machinations.
We can all get together and say, and if you say, well, well, uh, in astrology, Mercury
is communication and it's, uh, you know, it's school friends and it's technology.
Well, from the ancients perspective, right?
That was all tied into evil machinations.
Gossip.
Gossip is evil machinations, right?
Undermining people socially.
That's what they're talking about.
Um, which they would say is the root of those behaviors.
And I think so would evolutionary psychologists.
Right.
Um, and, uh, the sun is, uh, the arrogance of the ruler and wherever, you know, when you
look at an astrology chart, by the way, this is like a digression, but everyone focuses
on like sun sign astrology.
No one ever tells you that a certain percentage of people are going to hate you in whatever
house your son is in, like whatever area your son is in.
Right.
So if you're, if your son is in the 10th house, then you are going to have people in
your professional life who secretly despise you because your son is in the 10th house.
You're knocking the air out of the room, wherever you, your son is, right?
You're overshadowing everyone around you.
And that's where you express the arrogance of the ruler.
So there are always going to be people who resent you, uh, in that area of your life.
Um, uh, Venus is the illusion of longing.
Uh, Mars, according to the ancients was the, um, was unholy, um, presumption and like daring
recklessness.
So it basically is, uh, uh, not caring about anything, but doing what you want.
Right.
So that's like a, a big, like Martian, we have a tremendous Martian energy in our society.
Like we admire people who go, go for what they want.
Right.
Assertive.
We're not, they're not aggressive.
They're assertive.
Right.
We invented like whole, whole, um, categories of human behavior.
So not being aggressive, you're being assertive.
Um, Jupiter is huge.
So the reason that the Orthodox still have the aerial toll houses, but Catholics don't,
the aerial toll houses were converted into the seven deadly sins.
Right.
And if you look at the seven deadly sins, they align really perfectly with the ancient concepts
of the, of the spheres, um, except for Jupiter.
Right.
So, uh, and I'm, I am highly overweight.
Like I was in, I was fat before I was in an accident.
And then I was a wheelchair for a couple of years.
And I'm, I'm very big.
People tell me, don't keep mentioning that in spaces.
Cause you're, you know, you seem like you're, you have a hangup or something.
Well, it is relevant sometimes.
And it is relevant now.
Okay.
So I'm about to tell people that like gluttony isn't the only facet of that sin.
Right.
So it really Jupiter rules the, the evils associated with wealth.
And, uh, when the church, we can, we can, we can, we can,
we can hypothesize that when the church was expanding and they started taking in the money
and they wanted social recognition and social status, right.
Um, the, the attitude of the Christian community towards the wealthy changed.
We know that historic, we know that for a fact, um, we in this, in the documents, it's
also in the Bible, right?
Uh, so instead of saying the evils of wealth, um, they translated into gluttony, which is
one evil of wealth.
Um, I would not, like, I'm not a rich person, but if I was, if I had like a, a primitive level
of poverty, I couldn't be fat.
Right.
Like in order to, to, to, to, to physically be fat, you have to eat, you know, a lot.
Um, but other, um, evils of wealth, uh, could be like a lack of empathy for people.
Right.
Um, it could be a, um, well, shit, cause I don't want to get into politics.
And so economics is tied to politics in, in, in, in our society.
Just, you can imagine that a lot of things, anytime you're taking up significantly more
of your share of, of something, right.
Um, and a share, not your share, an equal share of something.
Right.
If you're taking up significantly more than an equal share of something, I'm not saying
you don't have a right to do it, but from the ancient perspective, that would be the
evils associated with wealth.
And as time went on, like, because, you know, Jupiter rules getting more than your share,
it, it, it's a, it's, um, a benefic, right?
So its effects are beneficial for the native.
Well, it's beneficial for you because you're, that's Jupiter rules, the area where you're
going to get more than an equal share.
So basically, and from a position of scarcity, uh, that's, that's the evil of wealth.
Right.
And of course, Saturn, we talked about that's the, that's the evil machinations that lie
in ambush, right?
That's trapping, setting people up, um, secretly or otherwise.
So those are like the seven basic patterns of behavior that the ancients were very concerned
about, um, and, um, in order to escape from this cycle, you had to overcome those patterns
of behavior.
I don't think you can do a shortcut just by being aware.
I don't think having extrasensory perception gives you a, uh, an out.
Um, and when I originally talked to Morgan and he was like, well, I just don't go, I'm just
don't go into the light and you're going to ascend and you're going to go to a place that's
like the next level.
And it's, it's paradise and the water is pure and the air is, like a lot of talk about
pure air and water.
And he's from, he's from Ontario.
So the air and water is pretty pure in Ontario.
So I don't know what the connection there was, but it was like deeply, deeply meaningful to
him.
But then later when he looked back at the session data, right, it showed that he kind of was
skipping over the, the, um, the, uh, corrupt legal proceeding.
Metaphorically that you would go through after you avoided going into the light, which again,
parallels going back to Zoroastrianism and ancient Egypt, like how they saw it, you know,
your heart would be weighed, you would be put on trial basically to see whether you should
go to heaven or hell or, you know, be reincarnated or being, be released.
Um, like I, it doesn't matter if you're aware or not, uh, because if you're aware enough
to get past that tunnel of light, then you're just going to end up, right.
Um, you're just going to end up having to answer for these, these traits and this, this
activity here.
And if you, if you believe the Gnostic principle that we are not here by choice, that we were
imprisoned, that still doesn't make it okay to behave whatever way you want to.
Right.
And the basic principle is that, you know, the archons imprison and oppress human beings.
And when we act arconically, we're imitating the archons, we're becoming little archons and
that will happen to all of us.
Right.
And when we do it, we feel guilty or ashamed later.
But there's some people who aren't right.
If you think about like narcissists and psychopaths, right.
Like real narcissists, narcissistic personality disorder, psychopaths, like they are little archons.
They're like the image of the archon in this world.
Right.
Little, little rulers.
Um, little, little wardens.
Okay.
And they don't feel guilty.
So, um,
I don't know if they're, that's another concept.
Right.
When you get into like, what is the soul and who has it?
But, um,
in order to eliminate those traits, you have to awake, awaken to the nature of reality.
You have to awaken to like, what's going on.
Right.
Like Buddhism has its eightfold path that is like awakening to the nature of suffering.
So it's very similar to that, except that you have to awaken to the nature of, I guess, imprisonment.
Right.
Um, and you have to awaken to the fact that when you, when you behave in these ways, when you behave in like negative ways towards other people.
And that's not like in a, in a, um, wishy-washy new age sense, but in a sense of like the, the seven points that we just went over.
Right.
When you behave in those ways, you're doing the archon's work for them.
You are, you're oppressing other imprisoned individuals.
And I know I've talked about this in other spaces for people who have seen it.
Like, I don't want to keep droning over, but that is why, um, you know, one, almost inevitably, when I talked to a remote viewer, who's looked at the simulation and I've seen this information and I continue to talk to them, uh, within one conversation, two at the most.
Uh, it'll come up with a now practice manifestation is a reaction formation.
It's like a reaction to, um, because they are now aware, more aware of reality, but they're not awake.
So they respond by reacting to that or rejecting it.
Right.
It's not fair.
It's not fair that I'm trapped there.
It's not fear that I'm, that I'm here, that I, I don't want to be here.
It's not fear that I can't, that people say it's wrong, that I want to X, Y, and Z.
Right.
Like it's, it's not fear that people say it's wrong, that I want to make a lot more money than everyone else.
It's not fear that people say it's wrong, that, that I want to live in a big heated house when other people are out there in the cold.
Right.
It's not fear that people say it's wrong.
Uh, you know, I, I, I, where I have some of those.
Right.
And, um, you know, like I said, I, I, uh, like I have medical reasons, but gluttony is gluttony.
And so if I was to walk around and saying, Oh, it's not fair, it's not fair.
It's fair that people say, you know, that it's, it's morally, that there's, that there's a moral implication to being obese.
Well, I mean, I could say that.
Right.
But I, I wouldn't be being honest with myself.
Like that would, that would, that would be awareness without being awake.
Um, so yeah.
And so the next step is manifestation.
And then people are like, well, I'm trapped here.
So this is the one life I have.
So I'm going to make it, well, not the one life because you can reincarnate, but, um, in their relief.
Right.
But it's, uh, like the illusion.
The, this reality is the only reality that we have from their perspective.
Right.
Cause we're trapped here.
So mine is well, live it up.
Mine is well, enjoy the benefits.
And then they, they start the manifestation shit.
It never works out.
Um, I don't think it works out for anyone, but it definitely doesn't work out for an aware person.
Um, so what happens, um, and this, this, you can, you can find this going back to the prophet Conner John as well.
Right.
So we going back 2000 years, though, they'll tell you is if you become aware of the nature of reality and you don't begin to change your life because of it, um, you're in trouble.
And, uh, specifically, um, the Apophicon or John, right.
That's just one book, um, of many, but it was like, sort of the first, um, you know, they would said you, you would basically, um, you're going to live your life in overwhelming poverty.
Like you'll, you'll be punished by, by living your life in, in such overwhelming poverty that you'll be trapped and you won't have any opportunity to, um, to make positive changes.
I can say that amongst, um, those of us who've had these inclinations, but didn't act on it at the time.
And I, I'm, I'm still glad that I didn't because when I started to come into this awakening process, I didn't understand, right.
These ancient texts, I didn't understand them until I met Morgan and I saw the, the modern RV data, which translated, right.
Which was said in esoteric speak into like modern scientific, you can say it's not scientific, but you know, they report things from a perspective of a modern person familiar with science.
Right.
Uh, yeah, I didn't understand them.
So like the first time I read the Gnostic texts in the nineties, like, you know, anytime I would go back and read them, I'm like, man, this is just crazy stuff.
It doesn't make any sense.
And so I'm glad that I didn't go out and start like, like I, I tried to immediately tell people the stuff that I knew.
And I kept doing that until I received such negative ramifications that I, that I stopped and I shouldn't have.
Um, so even though I had an imperfect vision of what was going on, I wasn't sharing the part that I, like, I stopped sharing the part that I like was aware of or, and you know, I think that that has had a profoundly negative effect on my life.
And everyone else I've run into in this situation has had the same series of events where they've become aware, including all these remote viewers who, this is what happens.
And they, they remote view these subjects, they become aware of it.
They react, they reject it, they react to it.
They start manifesting and they end up like their lives are a train wreck.
No offense to whoever's listening anonymously or will listen to this later.
I'm not trying to mischaracterize anyone, but you can tell from the fact that I keep saying that, that someone accused me of mischaracterizing.
Uh, and of being passive aggressive.
I'm not trying to be passive aggressive either.
Right.
So, um, what's happening right now, right.
To tie it all together is we are going through a forced awakening process.
Nothing can force you to wake up.
Right.
For, for many people, it may not be possible for them to wake up at all.
But the flip side of these, um, uh, of this, of these astrological, as the astrology again, is a representation of what's going on with us in our consciousness.
So, um, the, the flip side of these events, right, is as we see external to ourselves, the, the crusade, the crusades begin to try to change the world.
The, to, um, reactionary crusades to bring things back to how it used to be, um, or crusades on the other side to, um, because God knows these transits are, are very closely tied into communism.
And I hate to say that because, uh, it's on X and communism, the word is thrown around, but they are closely tied into communism and also tied into, um, geopolitics.
Right.
So as we start to see this crusading energy in the populace to make these external changes, to fix the world, that same crusading energy is a spiritual impulse.
That each one of us can receive to change ourselves, right?
Everyone is thinking that they're awakening, right?
So, uh, what do you see on X?
You see people writing about how, oh, I used to think this and then I took the red pill, right?
And then they woke up.
Well, usually the next 10 things they say after that are political virtue signals.
Oh, I'm going to, oh, one love coexist.
I'm going to prove you, but I'm just going to continue this, this to ramble for a minute.
And then, then I'll let you talk.
So they, they, they, they, they say they woke up, right?
But they're really just, okay.
They joined another consumption pattern, right?
It's, it's, uh, you know, they, they're just virtue signaling to a different group of people.
So everyone is going to think they're waking up.
We're going to see that in the UFO community.
We're going to see a great UFO awakening.
We're going to see a great Christian revival and awakening.
And I hope that sticks.
Cause I, I am a Christian.
Um, we're going to see political awakenings.
We're seeing a, um, I didn't, by the way, you popped down.
I think I was going to leave you up as a speaker.
So, um, you get to ask again, if you want to come up as a speaker.
Um, oh, you're, they, they fuck around with me all the time, dude.
Um, okay.
Now, okay.
Uh, so yeah.
What is this?
Um, right.
Everyone is going to think they're awakening.
Um, that's a, a, a facet of the conjunction of Saturn and Neptune, which is delusions, the ideal illusions, the collective unconscious, right?
And then crystallizing every 36 years, it crystallizes into real world challenges and restrictions, uh, both challenges and restrictions for us as individuals, but challenges and restrictions to the, the ideas as well.
Right.
So like Neptune is going through Pisces and the world has been kind of crazy.
And some of us, I'm not me, but I know there are people who might've like really been invested in those things that I'm just casually calling crazy.
And that's, uh, it's inappropriate.
And I apologize, but that's going to change.
Like it's, it is changing, right?
We've all seen it change.
It's not going back.
Um,
We're waking up to things every day.
Like I keep posting, right?
I post on my, on my, um, my, my timeline or whatever, or my, my, my account.
I post like 20 or 30 news items every day that are new news items involving awakening to aspects of reality that we are in denial to.
So massive economic fraud, uh, massive, massive fraud on the part of, of, of, of,
Um, uh, corporations and countries and individuals and, um, the awakening to delusions.
We're seeing right now, like a very strong moment of awakening, um, regardless of your politics, we're seeing a very strong moment of awakening to how some people feel of others who disagree with them can be treated in this country.
Whereas prior to this, there were always caveats.
And there were situational modifiers, but now I think like over the last few days, like people said, well, wait, you know, it is, and you could agree with this.
I'm not, I'm not taking it aside.
I'm saying like people waiting and say, okay, wait.
So there are definitely people who believe like, if you disagree with them and don't do what they want, then it's okay for you to die.
Like, that's something we're waking up to right now.
Right.
Before we, we kind of knew that, but now like, we, we definitely know that because the veil has fallen away and people are like, you know, before they were like, Oh, justifying and rationalizing.
They're not justifying and rationalizing it anymore.
They're being more honest than they were in the past.
Right.
This is also an opportunity for individual awakening and for individuals who do awaken to begin making the changes in their lives.
They can prepare them right for our encounter with our chronic forces following our apparent death.
Because that has to happen.
So you say like, how are these situations changed?
How does it affect escaping from the archons?
Well, it affects it because it's been sort of vague and nebulous, watery, mystical, intangible.
Right.
Like things we talk about, especially on like X and where everything's entertainment with the UFO X people.
I was like, Oh, what's he said that this is going on in reality.
And that person said, that's going on in reality.
And that person said, you should do this.
And right.
And now, like, it's going to be very clear.
And a lot of people are still going to do what they can still do the same thing.
But for those people who've been on the edge of awakening, this, this process, particularly over the next three to six months.
Right.
Could be a very real awakening.
And we know some people are going to awaken, like fully, because this is the time when, like, major spiritual movements begin.
And a spiritual movement can begin with one person awakening.
And most do.
Right.
Most of the religious and spiritual movements of the world begin with one person having a genuine awakening.
And everyone else gaining awareness from that.
Go ahead, Juan.
Yeah.
So my question is a first time listener, first time caller, by the way.
Thank you for having me.
You mentioned, yeah, you have all these people on X saying, like, you can do this, you can do that, this will happen, this will that, Ascension, 5D, all this stuff.
So I guess my question to you now is, so you're in a space talking, I guess, what sets your take on it different, or perspective, or do you agree you're kind of in the same mix as the rest of them?
Okay, so look, I repeat the same thing.
And so we've got, like, half a dozen people here who've heard this, like, 40 times.
So I don't want to, like, go on too long about it, but I will just try to reiterate it, because I know that you came in after.
We touched on this, right?
So, I spent about 30 years studying these subjects, without coming to definite conclusions.
I had some conclusions as a result of personal spiritual experiences.
So not spiritual awakening, but spiritual experiences, which are more along the lines of, like, an experience or thing, but not involving aliens necessarily, but just involving
personal awakening events, okay?
However, like, I, I, there was a lot that I didn't understand.
And in 2023 and 2024, I was approached by a group of remote viewers to work as an astrologer on a project with them.
Um, the Astro RV Project, where we would start working on using astrology to target, um, future RV predictions.
And I could get into that, but this isn't the time to go over that again.
But basically, if you utilize astrology correctly, it allows remote viewers to see the future more accurately and in a, in a much longer timeline.
Um, most remote viewers can make fairly accurate predictions, uh, six months to 18 months in the future, but no one has demonstrated the ability, uh, recently to do it beyond 18 months consistently.
And we think that the Astro RV Project will change that, um, during that period, I started to read their publicly available, uh, descriptions of this session data.
I read them three times and the first time I, I got very uncomfortable and then I went back two more times because I wanted to face the discomfort that I felt because I, I, I recognized that I was intentionally not seeing something.
Um, and third time I went back, I realized, um, that, um, what was implied in the publicly available data was information about, um, like the reality overlay, the matrix simulation, whatever you want to call it.
Right.
That they were touching on it in, um, in a hesitant and indirect way, but that was clearly what their point was.
It was clearly what they were avoiding.
So I contacted my associate who runs that remote view group and I had sort of a anxiety laden bottom line conversation with them where I was like, look, this is what you're saying.
And I think this is what you're omitting, right?
Probably because you're, because what I found in other remote viewers who looked into the simulation slash reality overlay slash matrix, whatever you want to call it, is that they tend to have like, either they renounce remote viewing and quit afterwards or the life hits the skids or they become vocal, like almost obsessive opponents.
Um, of the idea that remote viewing can answer questions like the nature of reality.
So clearly there's a reaction that people have remote viewers have after they look into these subjects and that reaction stems from the fact that they are so uncomfortable with the information they consistently get the perceptions they consistently get.
Right.
Well, what sets me aside from other people who've had this conversation is that I'm very familiar with.
Um, esoteric history, ancient clairvoyant movements.
So what happens in history is there are these major movements, um, that involve, um, esotericism and clairvoyance.
And when historians record them, they omit or minimize the influence of esotericism and, and clairvoyance, right?
So you will hear about movements like theosophy, right?
As a new religious movement in the 1800s, 1900s, but it's a lot more difficult to find clairvoyant session data from the individuals involved than it is to find books written about their movement.
So there are hundreds and hundreds of books written about their movement, but it is a, a feat to find what they actually, what the clairvoyance actually recorded.
And that's the case in each of these movements.
And the reason is they face either individual pressure or, or, um, negative ramifications in life from what they were doing, or at different points in history, they faced persecution.
As is the case of the individuals we now call Gnostics, right?
The part of the Christian church that was, uh, was cut out and removed from Christianity, uh, around the time of Constantine.
All right.
So they'd been around for hundreds of years beforehand and all of everything they wrote was gone, but then they found it buried in the desert.
Okay.
And they started to find it in other places as well.
They were able to validate the reality, but up until the 1940s, like all we knew about what they said was other people,
who were talking shit about them, right?
Cause everything else had been found and destroyed.
That's how deeply they've been persecuted.
So because I was familiar with that, when I went back and looked at the session data, um, uh, the recordings of the perceptions that modern remote viewers make,
when they look into these same subjects, I was able to recognize it that the same perceptions.
And once I was able to recognize it, the same perceptions, and I was also able to see them from modern context, right?
So, apart from Connor John, right?
Adam, the archons get pissed off at Adam.
So they take him away to a cave and they imprison him there.
And like, there's a whole description of what they do to him in this cave, but they put him to sleep, the state of death,
and they force him to reincarnate basically over and over again.
Right?
So they use, in that, they use the type of primitive descriptions that a person in the first century would use.
But when you see that same subject remote viewed 2,000 years later by highly competent modern remote viewers who have never spent a day in their life reading any type of fantasy, science fiction, any type of esotericism at all.
As a matter of fact, most of them won't read anything because they don't want it to affect their remote viewing supposedly.
Right?
So, again, most remote viewers won't do any research on any subject.
Okay?
And so this group that I was working with, okay, like they were originally five guys and they weren't even like city folk.
They were five rural individuals from America and Canada, and that makes a difference culturally, right?
Who got together, and this is my interpretation of what happened, okay?
I believe that they originally got together to use remote viewing to disprove all of the new agey conjectures that were floating around.
They're very, very anti.
All of them are very anti, like, they're just very against, right, any type of speculative science fiction explanation for anything.
It's like personal ideologies.
So I believe that they originally got together in order to counter what other remote viewers were saying.
And this was 15 years ago, okay?
Close to 15 years ago.
They didn't know anything about any of these subjects.
And they started getting the session data that was not what they wanted.
And two, three people, well, there's a whole series of events where basically three of them no longer practice remote viewing and were deeply upset.
And the other two just sort of ground to a halt.
Like, they have been running sessions for years.
They have tons and tons of session data.
They just cannot or will not release it because they don't want to be judged by people for what their sessions say, right?
But I was able to figure out what their sessions said just by sort of reading between the lines.
And then I was able to recognize that what they were saying was the same thing that Rudolf Steiner talked about, that Theosophists had talked about, the same thing Esoteric Christians were talking about, the same thing the Gnostics were talking about, the same thing the Manichaeans were talking about, the same thing that the Hindus were talking about, the same thing the Mesoamericans were talking about.
But ultimately, I was able to look back and figure out that they're all talking about the same thing.
They all saw the same thing.
So what separates me from everyone else is that I'm explaining what everyone, what all these clairvoyant movements have been hiding, right?
And our sources are not just this historical clairvoyant information, right?
But, you know, the recordings of the ancients themselves, right?
So we all know that this is stuff that is recorded in ancient, no, some of us know, that this is stuff that is recorded in ancient Middle Eastern, right?
Sumerian, we all talk about Sumerian, and Hindu texts.
I have been informed by an expert in ancient Mesoamerican texts that it's also encoded in ancient Mesoamerican texts, where they call the eighth sphere, right?
Which is what Theosophy or Rudolf Steiner would have called it.
They call it the White Castle of Death.
No relation to the burger place, I don't think.
So, yeah, so that's what differentiates is it's just a level of knowledge and a depth of knowledge.
And I've contacted, I've looked at, I followed remote viewing for about 30 years and since the beginning.
And, you know, I don't know everything.
I don't know everyone, but I consume every bit of public session data I can find.
And so I'm very familiar with the aggregate remote viewing session data on the subject.
And it is highly consistent.
So I don't think there is a source that exists that counters this information.
I think there are opinions that exist to counter it, but I don't think there's any source that exists and counters it.
Go ahead.
I'm fascinated by how you mentioned these remote viewers that came together to pretty much end speculation.
So I think that that's pretty, that's a pretty good movement there.
And you mentioned something that made me want to listen to you and have the patience as you explained yourself.
And it sounds like you've, you've mentioned how all these different points of view, the new age spirituality movement or the ET movement, how it's a lot of just a lot of different opinions.
And there's a lot of entropy and chaos that comes from it.
And you mentioned you're a Christian.
So it sounds like you've seen how all the entropy and chaos is no good and how, I guess, it led you maybe back to Christianity or maybe you never lost your faith.
But now, so now I'm kind of curious what kind of Christian you are.
And I, I too am a Christian and I've also been down all the rabbit holes as well.
So I would like to hear your, your take.
Sure.
I don't intend to affect anyone's theology.
Right.
And I usually do a disclaimer, but I don't think I did a disclaimer while you were here.
I don't want to affect what anyone believes.
I don't want to, and I never have.
And that was one of the things that motivated me strongly not to, not to promote anything for, for years because you take a tremendous responsibility on your hands.
Right.
Now I'm not telling people when you, when you interfere with someone's religious beliefs, especially if you, if you lead them away from the truth.
I don't look at anything that I talk about as being inimical to Orthodox Christianity.
I look at it as being possibly, well, no, definitely like not something that's a common understanding.
Right.
So are you in the U.S.?
Yes, I'm in Washington, D.C.
Okay.
So do we have cultural Christianity in the West?
Right.
Particularly in.
There's also FYI, I'm converting to Catholicism at the moment.
Okay.
Yeah.
Got it.
So we have a cultural Christianity, right?
It's based on presuppositions like the Bible is written for everyone at all times.
And so therefore it's equally valid to interpret it from the lens of someone living in Oklahoma in the year 2020 as it is for looking at the context of what ancient Jewish culture represented.
So ancient Israel becomes a reflection of the beliefs of the people of Oklahoma and Texas and that area, right?
Or wherever you are.
And that's not, you can study things that way, right?
And if it leads you to a belief in Christianity, that's great.
However, nobody who has gone back and looked at, you know, what actually happened in the ancient world holds that belief, right?
So that's why you don't find like biblical scholars who support the middle American view of the Christian faith.
So these, when you look at like, okay, you look at the term Gnosticism, right?
The Gnostics were around in Christianity until the time of Constantine.
They emerged around the contemporaneous or around the time of Christ and the apostles.
They're connected to the apostle Paul and the apostle John, right?
And you also draw from a text at the time called the Gospel of Thomas, right?
Which is not a canon text, as I'm sure you know.
When we look at what Christians believe at the very beginning, we don't really know.
We have Christian fathers, but they often contradict each other, right?
So in order to create a modern orthodox canon, what you do is you use confirmation bias.
So you take your modern opinion, you look back, and everyone who agrees was an orthodox Christian, and everyone who didn't agree was a heretic.
Now, that was unfolding at that time, right?
So people were dividing into groups and camps and criticizing each other.
Like, that's not something that only exists in retrospect.
However, what is now termed to be Gnosticism, right?
The Gnostics didn't call themselves Gnostics.
They called themselves Christians.
And, you know, they outnumbered what is now considered to be orthodox Christianity 10 to 1 for several hundred years.
So 50 years after the time of Jesus, right?
Nine out of 10 people who thought they were Christian hold beliefs that we now consider to be Gnostic.
And we know that both from the writings of the time, but also just from the grave sites, right?
Where they were marked differently, the gravestones.
So it was clearly vastly outnumbered them.
As time goes on, the arguments against those beliefs, right?
The first, like, people become less familiar with what the people actually believed.
So they make more straw man arguments.
And, again, it's informed by modern cultural context.
Okay, so I'll give you a great example.
Demons, right?
So our modern concept of demons is a medieval concept.
It's not a concept from antiquity.
They did have daemons.
So a daemon was like an invisible being, right?
Somewhat metaphorical, somewhat real.
But there were a whole gamut of daemons, right?
And as time went on, that term changed to demon.
But in that process, right, the other theology around the spiritual world changed.
So in Paul, right?
When Paul's writing, he doesn't say, our enemies are demons.
He doesn't say, you know, our enemies are the spiritual forces of hell that are demons that look like this, that come and do.
No, no, he very clearly says, our enemies are archons, archons and principalities, right?
What you see written in the New Testament says, our enemies are princes and principalities, is a translation, right?
It's a translation of the word archon, which does mean ruler.
But at the time of Christianity was very clearly understood to mean, right, the archons were the planets and the gods that ruled them.
Okay, so stated right in the New Testament, it says, our enemies are the archons.
Now, when is the last time you heard someone in Christianity talk about that, right?
Like, you won't.
You'll hear about demons.
You'll hear about Satan.
You'll hear about all of this theology that developed in the Middle Ages.
It's not theology of antiquity.
Hell, right?
The word hell doesn't exist in the Bible.
The word hell comes from Norse mythology, right?
Hell is a term for Norse mythology.
Now, Hades is in the Bible.
Well, I have a lot of my personal opinions, but at the end of the day, I'm becoming Catholic because regardless of what I believe, I'm just going to believe what the church believes until they believe something different.
So if my belief somehow changes the church beliefs, then I believe it's the true belief.
And until then, it's just an opinion.
Yeah, sure.
I have no interest in changing your beliefs in the end.
You asked me what I believed.
So I believed, to the best of my understanding, what the original Christians believed.
Okay.
But so, I mean, so are you Catholic?
No.
Why not?
I mean, I was raised Catholic, but the original Christians weren't Catholic.
Well, what were they?
I mean, it was diffused, right?
There were 12 apostles.
I mean, do you believe there should be one church?
So this is a debate, right?
Oh, not a debate.
So this is a space that was about a specific subject.
And I understand that your interest is in Catholicism.
And I understand that you're in the process of conversion.
So you want to bring that interest to other people.
But getting into debate about whether Catholicism is the real Christianity or not isn't really what the space is about.
So I do appreciate that you brought up, you know, you were following it and you brought up and asked questions.
You can go on.
I mean, I'm tracking the way you view everything, too.
But I feel like you know the truth.
So at the end of the day, you know, you can still keep going down the entropy or chaos or you can look at the sober truth.
The sober truth.
Yeah.
Well, look, dude, I appreciate you participating.
Right.
But clearly you saw the space and you knew it wasn't a space about discussing your conversion to Catholicism.
So you're being a decent guy about it, but you're also you're trolling us.
Right.
So I congratulations on your conversion to Catholicism.
I hope that you are happy.
Right.
And I hope that it it it brings you the spiritual fulfillment that you're looking for.
And I hope that you you're right.
Like, I don't know.
I mean, it's not about that.
I mean, like I could do remote viewing.
I could work for the agency.
Like I said, I'm cleared.
I live in D.C.
So it's like I'm tracking, you know.
Yeah.
I mean, look, dude, I just before we end off.
Right.
I'll tell you one last thing.
There's a book called The Teachings of the Twelve Apostles.
Right.
You'll find it a book in the old sense.
So the original Christians created a religious tract.
And the the Catholic Church for a long time said it wasn't real.
But they've they've now found copies of it in Catholic monasteries and whatever preserved from the ancient times.
Right.
So it's called the Dash, D-I-D-A-C-H-E.
The Teachings of the Twelve Apostles.
It was the first religious tract.
You know, like those little books that Protestants will give out or Jehovah's Witnesses will give out.
Like it's a religious tract.
Right.
And it writes down like the basic beliefs.
It summarizes them.
So the apostles had one.
And that wasn't like the this was before the compilation of the New Testament.
When the New Testament was still being compiled, they had a document that they gave to people who were converting to Christianity.
Right.
Called the Teachings of the Twelve Apostles, the D-Dash.
And it very succinctly summarizes exactly what they believed at the time.
Right.
So it may seem as if like these things are are unsettled.
But as time goes on, like this is a period of revelation.
And as time goes on, we are these things are being revealed.
Just like the D-Dash ended up being revealed.
So we know now.
Right.
So one interesting thing about the D-Dash is, which is closer to teachings of Catholicism than Protestantism.
Is the teachings about the rich.
Now, we know that the Catholic Church teachings about the rich changed over time.
Right.
We know that early Christians, they didn't just think that the rich were in trouble.
They thought anyone who even advocated for a rich person was in trouble.
Right.
So you weren't just a sinner if you were rich.
You were a sinner if you defended the rich.
So that's what actual early Christians believed.
And we know that because we have the documents.
Now, time has changed.
Right.
So you've got Protestant prosperity heresy.
Where they run out and they act.
You know, God wants you to be as rich as you want.
He wants you to have all the money so that the sinners don't have the money.
And you'll have the Olympic swimming pool.
And they won't have the Olympic swimming pool because you're, you know.
We know that's nonsense.
Or no offense to anyone who believes that.
But, you know, it's not.
It's non-biblical.
Right.
But we do know, like, you know, the original teachings of Christianity were extremely anti-wealth.
So that's just one of the reasons that that document fell out of favor and was mostly destroyed.
Right.
But at one point in time, that was the document that everyone referenced for what Christians believed or didn't believe.
So, I mean, I would say that what I believe is in accord with that document.
I'd just say that.
Right.
But, no, I.
Yeah, I mean, you don't got to overthink it.
I mean, there's been an institution here for 2,000 years.
They did the job.
And they're still here ready to do that job.
Hold on.
Let me tell you something interesting.
Well, let me.
So, I mean.
I realized.
Yeah, I realized what.
So, I realized what I was going to say.
Right.
And that is when you look at who was in charge of the early Christian church.
It wasn't bishops.
It wasn't, you know, there wasn't bishops, priests, or deacons.
It was prophets.
Right.
So, that's who actually ran the early Christian church.
That was who went from town to town, from house to house.
Right.
Who held the.
They called them prophets.
Before there was any priest.
Before there was any bishop.
You know.
So, I think that's interesting.
Right.
Because that's where the overlap is.
The prophets were clairvoyants.
Right.
So.
Yeah.
I'm going to remove you.
But thank you for chiming in.
And I hope that.
I hope that it works out for you, man.
Yeah.
I'm not trying to stop anyone from being Catholic.
I don't.
I don't ever talk about it.
I don't know anyone who's listening to these spaces.
I've never told anyone to believe religiously.
I've never told anyone they should have any religious belief.
What I've said is.
This is what these clairvoyant communities taught.
Right.
About the nature of reality.
I've never told anyone that it should infect their religion.
I don't think it should.
To be completely honest.
So.
And, you know.
Another thing.
Like.
You know.
We get to.
Oh.
They say this.
They say that.
Well.
You know.
The toll houses.
Right.
That was a Christian teaching for a long time.
It's still an Orthodox Christian teaching.
Right.
It was tied in.
Like I told you.
To what the hermetics taught at the time.
Like that is what they believed at the time of Christ.
And there was Christians and non-Christians.
That's what they believed the afterlife was like.
You didn't die and go to sleep.
And then wake up for the final judgment.
Like you went from planet to planet.
Now.
Theology changes over time.
I'm not telling Catholics what to believe.
I'm just saying that that's what they believed.
Right.
Because we would still.
It's.
I mean.
We know from the historical documents.
So.
Is there anyone else who would like to.
Yeah.
So Lou.
I don't know.
That's a long story.
Like.
I know he won.
Whatever.
Like he.
Exercised extreme patience.
To listen to me.
Explain things.
But you know.
I go to.
Great lengths to articulate every detail.
Because.
These are the type of subjects that you have to be.
Like comprehensive about.
Right.
Like we live in a.
Like this is what social media wants you to do.
Like social media wants you to.
Like take these soundbite positions.
Right.
So that someone can come in and say.
Oh you don't have to overthink it dude.
It says.
You know.
And they can.
They can counter you with a.
A soundbite position.
Right.
Like a virtue signal.
And so communication.
Has been replaced by virtue signaling.
And.
It was always that way with.
With most people.
But.
People who like.
Not intellectuals.
But you know.
It's not like people who.
Academics.
Intellectuals.
People with like strong hobbies and interests.
Would use technical language.
And complete language.
In order to discuss all these subjects.
When.
Social media.
Constrains us.
To.
Or.
Constrains to the habit.
Of speaking in soundbites.
And incomplete thoughts.
Right.
It's a way of controlling everyone.
And.
I'm not.
I'm not saying that from like.
A conspiratorial point.
It's a commercial standpoint.
Right.
It's a way of.
Of.
Limiting.
The influence that our beliefs have on each other.
And the influence that our beliefs have on ourselves.
Right.
So.
You can.
You can pick one.
Consumption pattern.
And you can virtue signal.
All day.
About that consumption pattern.
As long as.
You live the same way.
Everyone else does.
Right.
Like.
I want one.
And because I.
You know.
One love.
Whatever.
Aussie's one in the finger.
Right.
Like.
I want him to.
To go to heaven.
Right.
I want him to have a good life.
To have a happy life.
To go to heaven.
I don't know.
He's got bitcoin in his.
He's converting to Catholicism.
And he's got bitcoin.
In his.
Yeah.
So.
I mean.
Right there.
Right.
Obviously.
His conversion.
Is incomplete.
And hopefully.
The bitcoin will be gone.
At some point.
But.
Like.
I want him to do well.
And to have the future.
That he wants to.
To have.
Right.
But.
It's just.
He's just.
Exercising great patience.
To wait.
To hit me with.
Virtue signals.
Right.
Like.
And.
And circular logic.
Well.
You know.
I.
Leave the church.
Because that's what the church says.
And the church says.
That I should believe them.
So I believe them.
And I'm going to believe them.
And.
Was there only one church.
And what.
Was there.
Was Peter a bishop.
And.
Right.
Like.
It just.
It just goes around in a circle.
So.
Um.
And.
They don't care.
Right.
Like.
The people who.
Who.
Who run the world.
They don't give a fuck.
If he.
If he believes in Catholicism.
Buddhism.
Right.
Um.
If he's a Protestant.
Uh.
If he's orthodox.
Right.
Because the people who aren't converting to Catholicism.
Are converting to orthodox.
They don't.
They're not.
Buddhist.
Uh.
If he.
If he embraces.
Um.
Mesoamerican shamanism.
As long as he.
You know.
Pays his mortgage.
Works his job.
Um.
You know.
Goes to Starbucks.
And embraces.
Modern consumer values.
Right.
Because.
As long as you embrace those arconic values.
Nothing you say you believe means anything.
Right.
It's just.
Um.
Moral licensing.
It's just a way of excusing your bad behavior.
Um.
And I'm not saying that he does that.
Specifically.
Like.
I hope he's perfect.
Perfectly legit.
But.
Uh.
I.
Take people seriously.
When they show me.
How they've changed.
And no longer behave like other people.
As opposed to when they tell me.
Why it's okay for them.
Specifically.
To behave like other people.
Right.
Now.
I.
I know this is like.
Uh.
Um.
A different thing.
For me.
From.
For most of the people.
Who listen to Spaces.
Right.
But you know.
I'm.
Animal.
Like.
I didn't start off as an animal.
Rights.
Advocate.
But I have a strong love for animals.
And I.
I don't like animal cruelty.
Right.
And so one thing.
Now.
I'm not saying that.
It doesn't have anything to do with what love says.
Okay.
But it's amazing how much.
Time and energy is spent.
In the different religions.
On justifying.
Their.
Cruelty towards animals.
Right.
So.
That's like.
That's something that concerns me.
Okay.
Or.
Their pursuit of wealth.
For some.
Right.
Their sexual behavior.
Obviously.
That's not the case with the Catholic Church.
Right.
Or.
The evils of wealth.
You know.
Or the.
Any of those seven.
Right.
Gossip.
Or whatever.
So the Catholic Church is better.
Than most.
I think.
Than.
Than most people.
As far as like.
Its teachings are concerned.
But.
I don't believe in moral licensing.
I don't think that there's any.
Belief that you can hold.
That makes.
Your behavior.
Okay.
So.
That's where I'm coming from.
But yeah.
No.
Don't change any religions.
Don't.
It's definitely not about anything I say.
Now.
X has the.
Like.
Completely frozen up here.
So.
Oftentimes it freezes.
And like.
I can't.
Right.
Like.
I see the same screen.
So like.
One love is still up as a speaker on my screen.
Right.
So I don't even know who's here and who's not.
There'll become a time when I'll be just talking and talking and talking.
After everyone has left the space.
I haven't.
It hasn't happened yet.
Um.
But it's going to happen.
And this could be that moment.
Right.
Because if he's still up as speaker.
Then you guys might not be here.
At all.
If someone could.
Send an emoji maybe to let me know if anyone's still out there.
Lou.
I don't know if you're still out there dude.
Do you have any.
Um.
Specific comments questions or concerns.
Right.
So I went through like a long elaborate because.
You know.
People like one show up and they don't know what I'm talking about.
So I go over it again.
And you know.
It does take patience to hear this.
Like just.
Sort of going over from.
You know.
Like I go from fucking.
2,500 years ago to today.
And then someone shows up and he says.
Well can you elaborate?
Well what makes what you say different.
From everyone else on X who says that.
Well I got to go from 2,500 BC.
To.
To 2024 again.
Like I.
I can imagine that driving people crazy.
That would drive me crazy.
Too.
Um.
But that's the catch 22 they put people in.
Right.
Like if you.
If you're not comprehensive enough.
That undermines what you're saying.
If you're too comprehensive.
That also undermines what you're saying.
Right.
Because you're really.
They're not listening.
They're just trying to get to the point where they prove you wrong.
Well.
Yeah.
So Lou.
That's.
That's what.
It all has to do.
Right.
This is.
One of the things.
I don't even know if you're still there dude.
Okay.
You haven't sent an emoji up.
So I imagine you're gone.
But maybe you'll listen to this later.
Like one of the things that.
Um.
You accept.
When you accept this.
This view of reality.
Right.
The reality overlay.
Is it time itself.
Right.
Linear time.
It doesn't really work.
Um.
So the insistence that linear time is real.
Or completely real.
Right.
It doesn't work well with the concept of awakening.
Because really.
When you're awakening.
You recognize that the past.
You know.
The present in your past.
Right.
You recognize.
The knowledge.
That you had at that time.
About who you are today.
And it came out in your language.
And in your interactions with other people.
Uh.
Stories you told.
Right.
The.
Dreams you had.
Reality crystallizes into being.
And that's something that's always happening.
Reality is crystallizing.
Right.
Because this is a collective dream.
That's crystallizing into experiences we each have.
It always happens.
But there are points when.
Right.
This cycle.
The Saturn-Neptune cycle.
Right.
Rules the points when.
There are these major resets.
Right.
These major crystallizations.
And.
This one.
Is that.
You know.
Zero Degrees Aries.
Which is the.
The world point.
Right.
It's the ascendant of reality.
This hasn't happened.
I checked.
It doesn't happen every 6400 years.
I was wrong about that.
It hasn't happened for 6400 years.
But it can vary between like 4000 and 6000.
A year.
So I was incorrect about that.
And I should have checked it out.
But I didn't have a.
An ephemeris that went back that far.
And now we do.
So now we know that information.
But this hasn't happened for 6400 years.
Right.
This level of crystallization.
Crystallization of karma.
Crystallization of.
Of reality.
Crystallization of awareness.
And possibly crystallization of awakening.
This has not happened.
In that time.
So this is like the.
The go moment.
Right.
This is like.
We've all been waiting.
For a certain story.
Our lives have been a series of stories.
That reflect.
A certain story.
And this is that story.
Right.
That we're entering now.
And so.
This is the time.
When people can seriously.
Start to focus on.
Right.
If they believe.
In preparing.
For the possibility.
Of escaping the archons.
Right.
Or from one love's perspective.
The possibility of escaping hell.
Right.
Is this the same thing.
This is the time to do that.
And these are the ways that we do that.
We do that by awakening.
We do that by focusing on these.
Arconic traits.
Right.
And.
The specific steps that occur.
Once we're.
Deceased.
We have information on that.
From remote viewers.
And.
You know.
Clear points in the past.
It's not 100% consistent.
Because some of it's metaphorical.
But it's the whole.
Like not going in slight.
Preparing for the.
The trial.
Right.
And that's.
You know.
For one love's perspective.
Right.
That is a Christian.
Of course.
The final judgment.
Right.
So that's the Christian version.
Of the.
The trial.
That our soul goes through.
After we.
After our physical death.
Right.
But.
There's no way.
That I'm aware of.
The remote viewing data.
Is that some people.
Don't go through that.
But there's no remote viewing data.
That says how.
One can do that.
It seems like.
Something that.
Is related to a factor.
That we're not aware of.
Or perhaps.
Is a predetermined factor.
Right.
So I can't tell you.
At least at this point.
How to.
Ensure.
That you skip through the process.
I can only tell you.
What the process seems to be.
And how to prepare for the process.
Right.
And you know what.
If you're a good Christian.
Right.
You're.
You're trying to.
Overcome the seven deadly sins.
Right.
If you're a good Catholic.
You're trying to overcome the seven deadly sins.
As part of your preparation.
For the final judgment.
So what I'm saying.
While.
Some of the details vary.
Right.
Is very much in line.
With the same thing.
Right.
Which is.
You're aware right now.
But you need to.
You need to transition from awareness.
To awakening.
Right.
To a waking.
Moment by moment.
Daily.
Consciousness.
Right.
You know.
You go through your day awake.
As opposed to having brief moments of awareness.
And.
Instead of believing.
That you're making conscious decisions.
You have to pause.
Prior to making decisions.
Wait.
Until it can become a conscious decision.
Right.
And give yourself that pause.
Become in the habit of not.
Acting.
Until.
You've.
Centered yourself.
On these.
These moral principles.
And then act from that point.
Right.
Like those are things that you can do.
Now.
To prepare for.
No.
But you know what.
Going.
Attending mass.
As a Catholic.
I don't know.
I don't see.
I'm never going to recommend one Christian.
One Christian.
Sect over another.
Because I don't want to be responsible for.
That.
For other people.
I mean.
I guess you have to follow your own.
Right.
Discernment.
And what God tells you.
But if God tells you.
To be a Christian.
And to attend.
Do you feel that God is telling you to be a Christian.
And to attend church.
Catholic church.
Then you should.
Or Baptist church.
You should.
Or Orthodox church.
Right.
Because that is definitely.
As long as it's not moral licensing.
As long as you're not doing it.
To justify.
Everything you do.
When you're not a church.
Then that is a positive step.
In the direction as well.
Meditation.
Practicing remote viewing.
To give you greater awareness.
Because awareness is a prerequisite of awakening.
Right.
Dream work.
Dream journals.
But you know.
The most important thing.
Is your interrelationships with other people.
It always has been.
Right.
We live in a world where.
A world designed to tell you.
From an early age.
That your personal interrelationships.
With other people.
Your personal behavior with other people.
Means nothing.
Right.
Being contentious.
Causing problems.
Gossiping.
You know.
Fighting.
Stealing someone's girl.
Whatever.
It really doesn't matter.
Right.
Laughing.
Mocking people at work.
Or.
You know.
Just things that we're told.
Are small things.
That don't mean anything.
Your.
Personal relationships.
With other people.
Has always been the most important thing.
In the universe.
On this planet.
The people.
Well.
Because.
Right.
I mean.
Let's face it.
It's a.
You know.
It's a reality overlay.
No matter what.
Right.
So.
In this reality overlay.
Right.
The point of it.
Is our.
Relationships with each other.
From the Archon's perspective.
They want to farm us.
By stirring us up.
To cause as much trauma.
To each other as possible.
And then farm the energy.
And.
From our perspective.
We want to.
You know.
Cultivate.
Virtually instead of vice.
Right.
Cultivate these moral principles.
Or whatever you want to call them.
Right.
And.
Cultivate awakening.
And not.
Cause other people trauma.
And seek.
Forgiveness from other people.
For the things that we have done.
Right.
And.
In that way.
You're.
You're mitigating your trauma.
Your karma.
Right.
From the eastern perspective.
Then when bad things happen to you.
That's burning off karma.
And you make.
You know.
You try to make.
Amends to people.
And you try to be.
You know.
You try to not do those.
Seven things.
Right.
Not.
Not fulfill those.
Arconic behavior patterns.
So.
I'm just going to like.
End up talking in circles now.
I mean.
If you have any specific questions.
You can always.
You can always send me a.
A direct message.
If you're like.
Well this person said that.
Or that person said the other thing.
Because it's all very consistent.
I guess one.
I did do one.
Space on.
Magic in the noise.
And Sasha's material.
She did not look.
At the reality overlay directly.
She looked at the hill.
From the telepathy tapes.
And she saw the reality overlay.
And I think the main thing that.
That separates her from.
Other remote viewers.
What she saw.
Is actually.
Sort of in line with.
Something from the gospel of Thomas.
Which.
Basically.
Says that you should try to make.
Your life as notable as possible.
Not notable as possible.
Like from pursuing the.
Arconic traits.
But like.
Just doing things different.
From what other people do.
Because that.
You know.
That will lessen your chances.
Of being recycled.
Basically.
Which makes sense.
Elon Musk actually.
Talks about this.
Because he's a proponent.
Of simulation theory.
And he says look.
The most interesting.
Outcome.
Is the one that's conserved.
Right.
Because when you.
Run a simulation.
You're looking for the most interesting.
Or unusual outcome.
So.
If we're in a simulation.
Right.
What he would say is.
You have to be as.
Interesting.
As unusual.
As different from other people.
As possible.
In order to.
You know.
Make sure that you're conserved.
In the simulation.
Now.
Everyone else.
Not everyone here.
Right.
Everyone here is great.
But let's face it.
Most people in the world right now.
Are kind of being scumbags.
Right.
So.
The.
What you could truly do.
To be different from other people.
Is.
Is not be.
Right.
So it might seem.
It might not seem very glamorous.
To.
To try to focus on overcoming.
Those patterns.
And habits of behavior.
But it really is something that.
That almost no one does.
And differentiates you from.
From pretty much everyone.
So.
I think that's in line.
With what she says as well.
So look.
I have no idea.
If anyone is still here or not.
Because the screen has been just frozen up.
And I'm just been rambling.
I appreciate everyone.
And everyone will listen to my rambling.
I appreciate that one love.
Listened to me.
Long enough.
That he could.
Then prove me wrong.
I'm glad that he felt that he did so.
And he feels fulfilled by doing that.
And I appreciate everyone else.
Sally if you're still here.
I really appreciate you showing up.
Sal.
I always appreciate you being here.
Lou.
And send me DMs dude.
So we can clarify what.
What I'm not telling you.
Right.
So I know what.
Because it might just be slipping in my mind.
Sadie.
It's always great.
I love your posts every day.
Melissa.
Your most loyal person.
In my spaces.
I really appreciate it.
Kiki.
It's been.
It's good to see you again.
Emory.
Sinan you've been around a lot lately.
I appreciate that.
And Titans.
You've been here before.
I know that.
And you know.
The anonymous listeners.
Are probably repeat listeners too.
I know.
At least a couple people have told me.
That they listen anonymously.
So.
I appreciate them as well.
It's going to be 15 seconds.
And I'll do another space.
On a Thursday.
I think I'm going to do a couple a month.
And some will be on Thursday.
Some will be on Saturdays.
I'll post it.
In the.
In the discord chat.
And I'll also post it.
On my thread.
And if anyone has any questions.
About when the next space will be.
They can reach me through DMs as well.
I don't know what the topic will be.
For the next space.
Because I don't want to keep.
Talking about the same thing.
Over and over again.
And boring the shit out of people.
Even one.
One love was here for.
23 minutes.
And I bore the shit out of him.
So.
All right guys.
15 seconds.
Then it will drop.
Thank you all.
And I hope you guys have a great day.
A great.
Enjoy your blizzard.